This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well, no, well no, your mom's house.
Christina,
this is uh,
one of the last episodes Jean
ever here in this studio.
It is miss mom studio. Quick heads up
to everybody before I forget to say it.
We're taking Christmas week off, so right.
We're supposed to give you a heads up.
No episode. Christmas week.
I'm sorry. Um, it is our,
it's going to be our holiday week as well.
Uh, but we'll be back the week after,
so don't worry. Don't get
her genes in a tussle. Uh,
we'll be right back. But
um, that's that. Uh, Jean,
do you want to go ahead and
start? I would do my dates. Sure.
Oh Dude, I big debts. Go see
Christina doing stand ups.
Now we're talking Lavalle and disrespect
on this show about my big fucking tits.
January 10th. You want to see
some big tits at the comedy store?
I only do that for you. You know,
I don't even think it's that funny.
I just do it for you. Doing that
January 10th I'm at the, uh,
main room on the main stage,
as Tom Likes to say.
Go ahead and give him what
I do on the main stage. Oh
yeah. You dance for dollars,
right? Your heels. That's why you
gotta wear your boots and your leg.
Exactly where it just to
regroup. Ah, everybody's,
that's the uniform of the horror is
what you said. No strippers, strippers,
they were there.
They're basically nothing in their heels.
But then when they're off work,
yeah, they were those like ugg boots,
like the knee high, ugg
boots, the leggings and the
oversized sweatshirt. Yeah.
There you go. You got it
on. Got The uniform you got,
yeah. You're on. You're like,
ah, the slap. Yeah. Hours. Take a break.
I gotta pay my cell phone bill. That's
what I feel like they're always doing.
Painting that cell phone. They always
have the cell phone bill. You're right.
Why is that always the
burden in a cell phone store?
There's always a couple of hookers
waiting to pay their bill. Yeah.
Are you really to have slight
culture down? So proud of
you. Thanks. January 10th,
Hollywood,
California at the comedy store comes,
see Christina Dina
dancing on the main stage.
January 31st through February 2nd,
Denver,
Colorado. Uh, the comedy works in Dunton.
February 23rd, I've rescheduled that
Cherokee Casino Gig. It's now on,
uh, February 23rd and west
Salaam Springs, Oklahoma. Uh,
February 23 March 2nd,
Madison,
Wisconsin at the comedy club on state.
What's Madison? What is it like,
what do we say for Madison?
Mamason I dunno. Mad Town to me.
April four through six, Minneapolis,
tits at the acme. Come on your club.
I'm not been there.
May 10th and 11th.
Tempe at the Tempe on me Improv.
That was new. That was good. Yeah.
First good one in a while. Next June
20th through 22nd Washington. Dick.
Come at the Dick. Come
and prob tickets at. Yes.
Christina p online.
Follow me on Instagram at the Christina P.
Good job gene.
That's where I post some of the videos
that we play on the show and sometimes
can't play on youtube.
That's right. Um, there's a,
there's some good ones up there
right now on the, on the gram.
Um, it's good. Thank you Landon
for this instrumental. You can
always send your music, your songs,
your instrumentals to your
mom's podcast@gmail.com.
There's no house in the email address.
It's just your mom's podcast.
I have just added another show.
Thank you so much to the
Great City of Milwaukee,
Aka Milwak Emiley Walk K.
I'm going to be there April,
well at the Riverside theater
and we were adding a late show.
It is on sale Wednesday. Uh,
there's no presale code or anything.
It's just rolling right into an on sale.
I also added shows most
recently in Medford, uh,
which is just outside of Boston,
Tampa,
Louisville and Nashville.
Those are all on sale now. Tom,
cigarette.com/tour.
Thanks so much.
If you're wondering about the shows that
are coming for the second half of 2019,
sign up at my website,
you go to the tour page,
it prompts you and that's where you'll
get the announcements for all the second
half cities. That's like La,
New York, Minneapolis, Toronto,
Vancouver, Calgary. Um, the
list goes on and on and on.
There's a bunch of cities
coming more than 20, and um,
hopefully it will be
some slots in every town.
So let's road beav and also,
what was I going to say? What was going
to say? Oh, maybe some international,
that's what I was going to say. Are
you serious? Yeah. You're going to go?
I think so. You have to renew your
passport. Well, I mean, I'll do that.
I did let it expire. It's
upsetting. I'm just reminding you.
You are reminding me and I appreciate
that and I appreciate you. I appreciate,
appreciate you motherfucker. All
right Jean, it's rock and roll time.
We got a big episode. Got a great guest.
It's go time. You're ready? I'm ready.
Let's do it.
Thank you ma'am. I'll fuck with
clown. Look that up from Florida. Um,
I'm looking for my queen. Know what I'm
saying? Sean gotta be skin showing Barbie.
Fetch. You can be anywhere between, you
know what I'm saying? I just need man,
motherfucker Wiki
and juggle that look.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, it's Randy. Don't bring anyone loving.
Well,
go to your mom's house
saying, you know what I'm saying? Just
talking about it. Yeah, I know. Funny.
It is funny. I feel like we
need that back in our lives.
We kind of phase it out for him and we
go through cycles. We did go through,
is this guy a Juggalo? Exactly.
Yeah. Your Fridge. I Collette. Yeah.
Yeah. From Queen. No, I'm saying, you know
saying yeah man. You know what I'm saying?
Well I'm saying,
I will say he's got some of the criterion
for a perfect your mom's house video.
Let's review. Sure. Well man motherfuck
would clown looks. I'm from Florida,
so right away. Okay.
Location, location, location.
Where is he located? He is in
a bathroom. C Tile over here.
I think he's might be on the toilet.
Yeah. It's probably taking a shit.
He is not wearing clothing on top.
No, and I don't. Does he have nipples?
Are they just tucked in somewhere?
I don't know. He's got he's,
he's got a horrible framing.
Terrible underneath 10 close to
came to see the top of his head.
It's framed forehead to mid chest.
It's from below beneath you,
which is never good. Yeah. Um,
also I will say the one thing that
doesn't meet the requirements. Yeah,
the lighting's decent. Why did decent,
I was going to say sounds not bad,
but I want to make sure,
I think there's some background,
either television or radio
on or there's something on,
here we go, man, my fucking
went clown La from Florida.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm playing in the background
right there. Check. Sorry.
Ideal way to record something is always
to have other things playing in the
background for your audio.
Again. Yes, yes. And Queen.
No, I'm saying Sean Garden,
be skin showing Barbie Fitch.
You can be anywhere between, you know
what I'm saying? I just need some man,
motherfucker Wiki and juggle that look.
You know what I'm saying? If Yo, oh,
he's got a missing tooth up here,
well that goes without saying that all
of a sudden raises the points. You know,
like he was, there you go.
You were going to say? Yeah,
the lighting's pretty good,
but well I'm counting three,
maybe three that are gone from the top.
Yeah,
so that that does meet the
requirement. Sure. Three shop,
three top teeth are missing.
You get more points than three bottoms.
Why is that Tom? Well, it's like
you can, you can miss some bottoms,
hit someone with a smile and they might
not even realize it. You'll miss it.
That was the talk to you
for a while. I'm like, oh,
that guy doesn't have some bottom.
Sure you're missing top teeth.
People know right away. Oh, world sees
it. So that's kind of cool. Yup. Yup.
I'm also check check another box for the
unreasonable ask [inaudible] which is a
huge part of a perfect why mh video and
his ask is to find a perfect woman for
him. He's a catch. Yeah.
Boy. He to his credit though,
you know he wasn't,
he was just like,
you don't have to be skinny and you
don't have to be fat. He was just like,
I want love. That's kind of actually nice.
That is neat. And yet to be a juggle.
Let,
well,
I mean that's somebody that's also smart
because what he's saying is I prefer
somebody who has similar interests.
That's really what he's saying, St. Cloud.
But at least he's not like, you know, and
you gotta be a doctor, like he's saying,
he's saying be would be into what
I'm into. That's smart, you know,
be into being a dumb shit.
Like Damn Shit.
Talk like I talk all dumb and Shit,
you know.
But he is, I think actually, you know,
maybe Kyle Dunnigan could learn if
a couple of things, his profile and,
and you know what I will say of all the
unreasonable mail requests for females,
this one is probably the kindest.
Yeah.
He seems actually pretty nice that
we've had, have all our suitors. Yeah.
I might give this Juggalo a chance.
We had to rank Christine when just
done again, calling you Christine.
Thanks Todd. If we, if I could rank
my suitors. This guy is now at the top
of the tooth lists suitors.
Yeah. There's a number of them.
The whisper was probably the,
the worst.
That guy that was whispering into
his ladies. I was about to vomit.
We had no teeth when he was,
oh my God,
he was at singing to her and
he had the rotting teeth.
That was pretty bad. That
was the worst one. I,
but at least he wasn't a deck
like he was trying to woo her.
But the guy with the no teeth and
he's always watching television and
oh I can't I please,
why are you doing this?
[inaudible]
bad to these two fees.
Bad.
Cause if there's like a big crunch factor,
that's what setting you
off a little bit too.
Well and it's so up close to camera work.
They all have bad teeth,
but I don't have to see it so close.
It's true.
You might like whispering
and singing in her ear.
Yeah,
it's really,
yeah. Yeah. So you're saying that
bothers you some? That's the top.
The top, nastiest really.
Well I just, I don't,
here's the deal. Here's the deal, man.
That guy's nasty as to hate that guy.
But this guy will really insist
on romancing me and singing to me.
My favorite part,
my bad at all.
Whenever I talked to blue band
about these videos. This guy,
cause you know a lot of people, we
don't have names. Yeah. He'll just,
he'll blue blue bag just goes,
oh I got some more of the,
I'll make it calm guy. So he'll go, he
calls him the, I'll make you calm guy.
Even though we've played countless videos.
I'm like,
cause I always know what he's talking
about. I'm like I know that guy. He's
no, no, no, no.
We should do is when our guests gets here.
Yeah.
Let her see all these and then she has
to choose. Yeah, that's a good idea.
She will go with, well I got a
suitor that I want you to check out.
Actually no, just before she gets it.
Cause I want your real take on it.
Okay. So this guy, God,
he's having a conversation.
He's having a conversation right now.
We can't hear the other side of it, but
there's somebody actually talking to him.
So he's not making a recording as a pitch.
He's actually in conversation and we
have a recording of just his side of it.
You have to imagine what
the other is saying,
but it's, it really gets
going. I mean, just,
just imagine who's on the other side
of this and what they're saying because
here's what he is saying.
Okay?
You would be required to make daddy call.
Is that understood?
And it would be done in a way,
but you want to do either with
your body or a friend of yours,
that's your girl, that you can sell it
with picture and say daddy stroke to her.
All right.
Or a video that you found or something
that you think will make daddy score,
but that is like a hundred
percent on your shoulders.
I trust that,
that my baby will know daddy well
enough to know how to get daddy to come.
That's a big responsibility for you.
How do you feel so far? You know that
scene we play when Josh Potter comes,
that woman crying. That's how I feel.
Really. I don't like that one at all.
You don't like it? It's so gross,
Babe. What's the part you don't like?
Just the everything.
That guy's a scary
like it is making sure you're
always sage. No thank you. Secure.
Making sure your daddy's
there 24 hours a day for you.
Making sure you're not making
stupid mistakes. All right.
Make sure that your grades are good,
right?
You sure that your relationships in your
life are solved and making sure that
when you melt down and have a bad night,
I am there all night long with you.
Sounds like a little not healthy fantasy.
Hmm. I don't like it. Well here's
a neat thing now if you want,
look on the bright side,
he checks a lot of the boxes.
Have a great video for this show.
Background is horrendous.
The background is a disaster
and I think doctor drew,
if he were here would be like this guy
might have a little sense of delusion
going on. Lots of it. Yeah.
It doesn't appear that he has a headboard
or any kind of framing on the bed.
It doesn't look like he
has even a nightstand.
There are just boxes or books
and things on the floor.
I need somebody in nightstands.
I mean where does he put like
his glass of water or his phone?
Like just a bunch of shit on the ground.
Uh,
he's lit from the computer
screen. Uh Huh. Um,
it's tear. At least he has a
shirt on, which is disappointing.
It's really disappointing.
Just this would be a rock and roll
hall of Famer if he were shirtless.
He has his teeth again,
bomber upsetting,
but he's uh, he's kind of much scarier
than the other guys. It's demonic and,
and it seems like he wants to own somebody
has the ask is, is really a lot. Yeah,
but you get that will
surpass any thing you've got.
Cause it's all conditioning.
It's not based on how you,
the stop based on your
performance intimately.
It's not based on your makeup before
your clothing or where you live or your
upbringing.
It's based on you being my baby and me
being responsible for making sure you're
always okay.
That seems nice.
All this to make him calm,
everything is related to coming.
Right. It's so elaborate.
Like it's just to make him
calm. Never stops it. No.
Ah Yeah.
Like do you realize how much energy this
man is putting towards getting what he
needs? Just to have a good
orgasm and he's not a young guy.
Here's a man that old, right? He's not an
elderly man in his fifties I'm guessing.
So is is coming really
that big of a priority.
It is interesting though
that the late like to him,
he doesn't want to go out to a bar and
and or sure reduced to a woman who could
make them come because that
woman's not going to be at he,
he needs it to be a submissive,
he needs a baby. Yeah. Pacific.
And so he's got like a really interesting,
uh,
psyche and mind game that needs to happen.
Yeah.
This is definitely a drew thing. I
want to put this on the list. Yup.
Do you love the idea of having
the daddy there for you?
I'm going to fucking be here. Okay.
Okay. Can we stop this? Is there a
my time is with you. You got to take
care of Daddy's cock. Okie dokie.
I'm done. Thank you. It sounded like a
nice pitch for a second. It was like,
I'll always be there for you no matter
what. You know, all these things.
But then he, he, he tagged it with
you got to take care of Daddy's cock,
you know?
Okay,
this is what you need to decide because
I can't spend all my time with you.
Shut off every other baby
that's interested and then
not emptied on a regular
basis out.
There we go get emptied
talk and daddy will get hard
and you should send us that.
We'll know that and know, okay,
I need to fix daddy. Yeah,
it's real weird. So creepy. Why has
it got to be in the terms of data?
I can like it and his skin looks like
it's going to peel off and this does have
bad skin, which again,
bonus, but you know,
it looks like really rang a shirt,
but you do have really bad skin.
It really enhances the look more
the part that daddy's got it.
I got out since this is daddy gets mad
at you for reasons I shouldn't be mad at
you. Dope. So this is where you
need to at least be mature enough.
Even any framing to accept
that responsibility,
to have that response except the rules.
The daddy was up for you.
Such a big responsibility.
What fucking website?
This is not how you normally,
uh, court people. Jeez.
I thought a Craig's list ad used to
suffice and this guy has got real demands
happening. I mean, are you turned on?
I think my vagina just sewed itself shy.
It just imploded on itself.
How?
I don't understand.
I really don't have to know how these
people have so much time about what makes
them come and the specific,
the specificity of what makes
them calm. It's like, oh,
come on. Just stop being fucking
weird. You know what I mean?
That guy's pretty weird. Oh,
he's so nasty, Todd. Yeah. Again,
and he also does the same thing that
the four, the four stroke guy does,
where he repeats himself. He's like, you
have to make daddy can't, like, yeah,
we know asshole. He careful it. Just
a hoard. Yeah. He, he keeps
repeating. If I got it, bitch,
that's how I feel. I think that was
the other side of the conversation
as he was doing it. He's
like, Daddy, come on,
kill myself. Listen. Yeah. Okay.
No, I don't like him anymore
because I can't spend all my time
with shuttle every other baby.
That's interesting. Yeah.
And then, yeah, you know, but
you know what that's like Tom,
when you're interviewing babies and they
all get your hard and none of them are
getting you off like you want and
you're like, which one are you?
Babies is going to Jack my deck. And it's
so frustrating when they don't. Right.
It is frustrating. And I want you
to understand this is the agreement.
I'm going to be there for you,
but you've got a sense when I'm hard,
this is a reasonable thing. The
adult baby people, which we've,
we've featured before on your mom's house,
uh,
the woman who likes to be the
baby and then the guy you know,
pushes her around in a fucking
pram or whatever, they love it.
People love this stuff. That's true. Hey,
I'm guessing to, we didn't play all the,
uh,
how,
how amazing Regena's
video affects face space.
Excite my mind's on the Christina
p right now on Instagram.
If you want to see the ones that didn't
get played. Kidding. No. Or at least one.
You want to see it? I ain't kidding
me. It's what I live for. Look, Julia.
That's terrifying. That's me as
Joe. That's extra terrifying. Yup.
Wow. Oh Jeez.
Did we play the urine
enema? We did. Right? Yeah.
Okay.
Rain.
I'm going to give myself a
urine anima. Um, people, uh,
are still continuing to send in
their look alike shops. You know,
I get so many of Garth, no, no. People
who I look just like, oh, right. Yeah.
Tom Twin photos.
You know,
if you're not subscribing to
your mom's house on Youtube,
please do so immediately so that you can
see these photos of people are sending
Tom photos. They're like,
you look just like this guy
happening. The story is this.
It's been happening. It's been
happening on Twitter, emails, Instagram.
People were like, dude, my
fucking friend is your twin.
Or like my brother looks just like you
guys are exactly how your doppelganger
and what will be the same is that
it's a human male with facial hair.
The beard. Yeah. Well that guy, hey man,
we're twins.
They never do.
They never looked a little bit. I can see
why he had the dark circles under his,
I mean, but you're talking about
some features, but people are like,
you got to see this. Like you're going
to get freaked out. Okay, what is it?
There's a guy with a beard. I'm
like, okay. And I look exactly alike.
No we don't. He's got
hands. You got hand. Oh. Oh.
And these are just a bunch of
dudes and panties. Tight pants.
Which ones you again, the black guy. Um,
well that's where you're looking
at an hour. I know. All I know.
Talk to my shrink about
it. Clear. And uh, oh,
this one. I've gotten a lot. This Dj.
That one's reasonable von stroke. Yeah,
that's reasonable. It's reasonable enough.
Especially when I'm in the DJ gear.
So like here he's wearing sunglasses
and a hat and a black tee shirt and I'm
wearing sunglasses.
And a hat and a black tee shirt.
And we both have beers with
similar. All right. I get it.
But I mean come on most of the
time, which I mean, it's just a guy.
Yeah, it's not your twin. If it's
just a guy that doesn't work,
that's most people's criteria.
Some actress that plays Supergirl. I get
sent that one a lot. I'm like, all right.
Maybe if I was 20 years younger.
Yeah, man, I'm like way cuter.
I think she's a little bit curious to me.
Mm hmm.
Uh, Ben Dover. Fuck. Um,
why don't you play that fucking daddy
calm guy? No, I'm all traumatized.
God. Yeah, I don't like that stuff, man.
Here's an email. Hey Tim
and Krista, I keep calling.
I keep telling Garth to fart on his balls.
Every Instagram post
I have even asked for his pay pal
so I can contribute to his cause,
but nothing has gained.
Maybe once the mommy's get his attention
and he agrees to come on the podcast,
you can both fart on each other's balls.
That would be my dream come true.
But what's wrong with you? Who's writing
this? Thanks for everything you do.
Truly a mommy kiss on me and try it
out. Like code stroke, four times slept.
You guys,
Travis from British Columbia.
You think if we could
get Garth on the show,
which would be a dream come
true that we'd be like this far.
Don't each other's balls. Yeah, of
course. That's what everybody wants to do.
There's no way that would happen.
That's what everybody wants to do with
Garth Brooks. That's why he's so famous.
Don't you know he meets all of his fans
after his arena shows and then he farts
on all their balls. Okay. Uh,
here's another email. Would it
do that? I would not. It says,
Dear Tanya and Chris Stobo.
I'm messaging in regards to that Harry
boy who didn't like the toilet paper
supplied by his college.
I was once in the same shoes as him
as a fair low hairy bear. Harry boy.
I noticed the half ply bargain shop roles
would terrorize my tush and destroy my
dupa. So I came up with a unique
and cost effective solution,
use the handicap showers.
There were no handicapped
folks in my dorm,
so I would simply use the toilet
for my Duke. He's before showering.
Then simply use the handy dandy movable
shower head to spray a geyser of
pressurized water up my
Coolo thus cleaning my hairy
ass deeper than any toilet
paper could ever dream
of. Try it out. Wa Hunter,
now they added more mois or something.
Brilliant.
Speaking of those,
um,
the Giulia full throttle stuff has
obviously gone full throttle. Um,
thank you so much for
the,
uh, the uh, shirt
purchased is everybody loved those.
The socks should be up now if they're
not checked back in a couple of days,
they're good morning Julia
socks with the fan zone and,
and literally hundreds of videos come
in and we just can't play them all.
But we did a few other selections here.
One thing before we continue on this.
Yeah, go ahead. Nothing
makes me happier in life.
I think in just in general as when
silliness is taken very seriously.
The fact that every now and
then you'll be like, oh my God,
you won't believe how many people are
purchasing the good morning Julia or the
full travel shirts.
And it makes me laugh so
much and it brings so much
joy to my heart because in a
world of just, you know
what I mean? Real stupid,
real things that something
like this taking on and, and
making people happy. Yeah.
That's great. It's just warms me.
Yeah, it's really great, right? Yeah.
The show is so fun.
It's so stupid.
Find silly things and then get other
people excited. It's so exciting.
It's so exciting. That is, that
really is was people like, and we all,
we're all in the same stupid joke. I just
like it. I like it too. I like it too.
It makes me laugh. Okay. What do we have?
Here's a couple more. Good morning, Joe.
It's me, Melissa. So
Darlene, you yesterday,
outside of the home depot was the greatest
moment of my life. There is a fight.
It's been sticking in my mind the way you
said that you were thinking about mark
and another video for Giulia.
Go Raisa from your past.
So Raisa from your memory,
you know,
sometimes we think somebody
is the right fit for us.
We meet them outside of a gym.
We exchange phone number as
we give off creepy vibes.
But see myself having a future with you,
fallen in love with you and I
think we should go full throttle.
Wish you a happy holiday
and uh, you know, again,
let's go full throttle.
Ciao.
It's very cute. More with
the message to Joe. Yeah.
To maybe get over his past here is uh,
Michael.
Good Morning Julia.
I want you to open up your heart.
Well, I can do it for you either
way. Just want you to know that,
that can't wait to wear your skin,
my skin and a way your face on my face.
And uh,
you know,
I know you want him to go to get back
to the ex boyfriend and I'm just telling
you now you can't. All right. You
won't be able to find them. I mean,
I admire you for the rest of my life.
I'll never let you go and I can't
wait for you to be in my basement.
I built with my bad hands anyways, Babe.
I just want to let you know that, uh,
I'm a have you in my grasp, whatever.
All right, I love you. Ciao.
The infamous [inaudible]
and one last one here.
This is from the various
just sitting here tired on the couch,
you know,
gotten wrapped around your
finger. You know, like Joe's
Q and a
native
comments today about your
tools in this love is real.
I could feel the Hay.
Good.
This guy, he's done a few. Yeah,
the one, what's his name is Raymond.
This guy's hilarious.
Yeah,
we've got a whole new good morning
Julia Lane. Now with this third,
why am h exclusive release
courtesy of Julia herself?
If you have not heard this episode,
uh,
Julia herself gave us a video no one's
ever seen before and it was a y IMH
exclusive of Joe laying on his
couch and the dark. It's horrendous.
It'll make you want to vomit a,
you got to try it out.
He does his laughter.
I'm so disappointed
going wrapped around your finger.
You got, you're cute.
You're cute. Cute. Yo,
you're cute.
All right, well this is, um, man, this is,
this is so fucking good.
Um, so with the, you know,
every time one of these
things gets big on our show,
Fart Simpson makes a prank call.
Yes.
He made one for Joe.
Oh,
God just gets better and better.
It's so funny.
I feel like I should mute our lines.
10 want to listen so you can
like really enjoy it. Um,
so here he is again,
always crushing with the prank calls,
but this one is as smash. It's,
it's Bart Simpson with the,
uh, show doing a, uh, a call.
Okay.
Hello, this is Kevin, the
store manager. May I help you?
Hey Kevin. My name is Bert Cohen
and regards from my father,
her harder. And so, uh,
my dad's been a handyman 35 years now.
What's your dad is a name
Hi Rama puts you on the phone.
Maybe you can just tell him a little
bit more about the job. His name's Joe.
Oh, okay. Awesome. Okay.
Okay.
The morning. Me. Joe. Hello. Joe.
I'm a very handy guy. Oh, okay.
Just wanted to say again.
I built everything.
Every square wrench from crown
molding, chair rail survey. Yeah.
The floors to lighting, to
plumbing, doors, windows.
And so this is the type of
guy again. Okay. I love to
build you. Whatever you want.
I just want you to know that,
hey, let's make it happen. Um,
they're so
your heart to make in your
arms how beautiful you are,
the man.
Okay?
Yes. I mean, just, you're gorgeous.
You're precious. I cherish you.
Have you turned in an application?
I will love you like you never
been loved before. Uh, um,
come in and get to read heart.
Let's go full throttle, okay? Okay.
I look forward. I'm going out
to dinner with you. Come in and
e and e,
z a is the one that's handling all
the incoming and outgoing people. So
I could see me falling in love with you.
Anyhow, I'll make you feel like a woman.
A real woman. Okay. Do
Ciao Baby. Okay. Right.
Can we hear it again? I have to. Yeah.
This is my favorite thing I've ever heard.
Oh my God.
Fucking Bart Simpson.
God Damn it.
The guys' reactions,
Huh?
Okay. He's totally so, so
sweet about it and you're like,
oh my God, hang on a pull up because I
think, uh, oh my God, I'm dying. Please.
I need to hear it again.
I think he emailed me that part.
Um,
so fun. I didn't realize
how much the stupid stuff,
Joe lists that he's built until I heard,
I didn't realize like how much he says,
you're like, oh, that's crazy. Who says
that? And like, uh, according video,
Holy Shit,
you turn this,
this stuttering [inaudible]
cause he's throwing so thrown
by a guy being like, oh,
I can see myself falling in love with you.
Let me treat you like a
woman. Is that okay? Yeah.
And you'll open up your heart
and your arms. Your arms to me.
Oh my God. Hi, please. Again,
I just wanting to give
a shout out to his site.
Fart simpson.bandcamp.com what his
a prank call masterful this one.
Master phone. You hear it again? Let's
hear it again. Let's hear it again.
Hello, this is Kevin, the
store manager. May I help you?
Hey Kevin, my name is Bert Cohen
and regards from my father, uh,
harder. And so, uh, my dad's
been a handyman 35 years now.
Hey, a bird. What's your dad is
heroin will puts you on the phone.
Maybe you can just tell him a little
bit more about the job. His name is.
Oh, okay. Awesome. Okay.
The morning. Me, Joe.
Hello Joe [inaudible]. I'm a very handy
guy. Oh, okay. Just wanted to say,
I built everything,
every square wrench from crown
mold into chair rail surveys. Yeah.
The floors to lighting, to
plumbing, doors, windows.
And so this is the type of guy, okay.
I love to build you. Whatever you want.
I just want you to know that. Okay?
Yeah. Let's make it happen. Um,
so to me,
in your arms,
he turned how beautiful you are to me.
And you just, you're
gorgeous. You're precious.
Have you turned in an application?
I will love you.
Like you never been loved before.
[inaudible] heart.
Let's go full throttle. Okay. Okay.
Going out to dinner with you. Come
in and see he and he's the, uh,
he's the one that's handling all this.
Somebody else,
I could see me falling in love with you
anyhow. I'll make you feel like a woman.
A real woman. Okay. Do
Ciao Baby. Okay. Right.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. He goes, yeah, he is.
Have you filled out an application?
God,
that was perfect. Perfect. Fucking,
oh my God. That's a perfect,
perfect.
You know what I always think like,
what would I say if I were on the
receiving end of a car? A car like that.
Like what would you, how is things
like, what would you do? You'd be like,
oh my God. What? You know, I don't
know what I would do if I was at work.
Someone call me like that make
you feel like a real woman.
So ridiculous.
Okay man.
The fucking hurt. Yeah. My face. I
haven't laughed that hard in a long time.
Um, except for yesterday when we
recorded it. Another shot. I know.
Uh, that was, thank you.
Thank you for Simpson.
Open up your heart to me in drums.
God or handyman store guy.
The chair,
he talks about so many dumb,
like listening to the list
now I'm like, oh my God,
this guy is. But that's what he was
trying to impress Julia with. Right.
It's both of it, but it's so
calming. Yeah. Like what are
you doing? They'd be like,
keep talking. God, you
did the windows so hot.
Okay.
Right.
It's such a strange wooing tactic.
It really in his mind when
he lists all those, yeah.
What's going on on my
right. Turning you on. Yeah.
And that's his, but that's his angle.
He's like, look, I can't go for looks.
You know, he's not, he's not going to be
like on the hottest guy in town. Right.
I'm not the richest
guy in town. Right. Uh,
but I wake up really early and
I build a lot of shit. Right.
That's crazy.
He's crazy.
I really am excited.
Now
you get our guests to check out these
different men and get her take on them.
You know, I can't even imagine
what leave she's single.
Maybe she'll be interested,
you know,
she probably gets these in real
life. Maybe we can ask her. She,
she's single and she's in the public.
I've heard dms are open.
There's definitely some
crazy shit going down.
She might actually seem like, oh, I
remember him. I know this guy. Yeah.
Yeah. Well it should be here.
She should be here momentarily.
Why don't we just take a quick little
break here and um, you know, we'll be,
uh, we'll be right back and
might acuity power. Um, okay.
We're back. And you, you, you just said
you'll be careful not to kick the tripod,
but also we don't have to worry about it
because this is the last episode we're
doing here.
You're the last guest.
Okay. Yes. I would appreciate that.
You don't do it.
It's not just because it's the last one
doesn't mean that it should keep still
wobble. Wobble. Don't break
my shit. You're moving. Yeah.
Oh, have you showed people your news
sleep studio? They ever see any, oh dude,
it's so cool. Pretty slick stuff.
Neat state stuff. Raw stuff.
So exciting.
You're lives are the greatest
lives of anyone I know.
And I'm just projecting everything
that I want your lives to be on too.
Slick stuff. Neat stuff.
Yes. That's Garth,
Garth Brooks one and only course.
How can I be relentlessly attack?
And it was like, he's so nice. Um,
you say that.
So you this and I thought this the
other day at the comedy store and then
Christina is same. Same thing. He said
the same thing. You, I feel like you have,
you're putting off very, my life
is good vibes. I get like that.
You got your shit when
you have winter vibes.
I feel it. I feel good and a
lot of people tell me that,
that they get that sense from me.
But, um, I am definitely on a,
I hope it's a trajectory cause I'm not
where I want to be yet. Like, you know,
it's, it's an I'm going up
but, and so it's looking good,
but I'm not there yet. In terms of like
strictly career, you just mean in life,
in all, in all, in all senses, but
also career, career actually, I'm like,
I'm very happy. It doesn't
get any better. It's fine,
but it's definitely going to get better
because that's just where it's going.
And that seems fine too. But, um,
I just remembered that when I saw you
the other day, but like a few months ago,
he's like at the store and you're like,
I'm about to do this thing.
That'll probably, I just can't. I
was like, what? And you're like, I'm,
and I was like, what does it, and it
was like the next day or two days later,
I saw an Instagram. I was
like, Nicki was on dancing.
It was so random. I'm like,
I know that come about.
I got a call from,
you know,
the call you get from your agent and
manager will call, call the double call.
I got a double call right after I had
finished doing radio and a big offer and
they're like,
we're just calling you to go because I'm
making sure you're going to definitely
say 10% of both. I have never
even thought about it that way.
I don't get many office unfortunately,
but it at a point in my career
where things are going well,
when I get the double call, I know it's
going to be good news as opposed to bad.
No one is calling to drop me right now.
That'll come,
doesn't know where it goes away,
but they don't do a double phone when
you get old like 45 46 but then there was
no double for the firing.
They pick one cowardly and sometimes
they don't tell you at all.
True, true. That's another way.
But get dropped like that. Once
I got dropped by an agent who switched
agencies like they're just like, oh,
he's gone. And I'm like, but it
doesn't even just send the, like,
I enjoyed my time working with you.
I'm moving to keep a connection there
where now and now you see them and you're
like, hey man. Oh, there's so many
people like that that just when you,
when you're coming up and you're nobody
and they treat you badly because you're
nobody, and then now they're not like
the most cliche thing, but it happens.
You see it so much and I just go your
fake because you were mean to me last time
and stub me. What's fascinating
is that it's always caught me.
Now we're doing this a while,
but is that you go like that decorum,
that way of being like
treating someone is not,
it doesn't exist in any other business.
You know what I mean?
Like if you worked in finance or
sales and like a manager moves on,
you would call like your team and be like,
I enjoyed working with you.
I'm leaving to work at this other company.
It's almost a form letter for that.
There's a way to that's conducting
business in that business.
But it's so funny, the rules
that we do all have to adhere by,
which is um, you know, managers don't
poach like a certain rules like that.
They have their own stuff.
It's game on.
It's so weird to me that
there's this, it's, it's not,
it's an unwritten rule,
but it's a rule that with managers,
you can't talk to another manager
if you currently have a manager,
but the agents don't adhere to that rule.
It's not the same rule.
Why does that not go for both of us?
I think because the managers,
except that they're supposed
to be your partner slash.
Friend. Well, they're the
long haul. It's the long haul.
The agents except that it's a numbers
thing making money and it's more personal.
It's family that's supposed to, that's
why I'm like, okay, well that makes sense.
The agents are fish,
dysfunctional family
and that's also the tactic is like we're
family now so that way they get away
with murder.
With ew gross business.
I recently had to leave someone
that I didn't have a problem with.
It was just like time to move on.
Yeah.
And nothing personal
note like it was so hard,
but she handled it so incredibly just no
bitterness and you get worried in those
situations.
It's like when you break up with someone
in their main and you're like, oh,
I'm glad I broke up with you, cause your
announcers. But um, she was just like,
and I'm like,
you're one of the good,
well I'm glad that I knew it was
such a thing. Made me feel so good.
She's smart because guess what?
I might come back or rent and people
change jobs and change all the time.
Yeah.
That's why I always tell people when
they don't get picked for this thing or
that thing in our business,
it's like, dude, don't worry,
the gatekeepers change every few years.
If you don't get this thing now,
guess what,
that person's going to go somewhere else
and that person's going to get hired.
That might like you wait a little
bit longer and nice to every night.
Yeah.
He cool a
doorman who are executives of course
or Adam Devine's doorman became Adam
divine. He was a doorman and
then Improv. Yeah. And know that.
But that's true. I mean like
anyone offer him, but yeah,
I hear he's doing all right. I think
he's, he's always been the sweetest.
Sweetest. Yes. Always the sweetest.
I that's the advice I always
give up and coming comedians. Um,
when they,
you know,
they asked you for advice to the MC
is working for your or a guest set.
It's like, well, can I get some advice?
Which I'm always annoyed by it
because I never did that to anyone.
I never asked Comedians for advice.
Did you guys do that?
Did you ask them to watch your sets? Did
wise. Here's why I did it too though.
Phyllis Diller. All right, Phyllis fucking
day, but she was nice. She was old.
I read her book and I was so inspired.
I sent her my set and I wrote her a letter
and fucking three days later Phyllis
Diller called me,
gave me notes on my act and it forever
changed what I was doing and everything
changed for me. Oh my swearing.
She was the nicest lady.
That's so cool to shit at that point.
Super Sweet.
Very rare.
Accessibility in social media.
Hey Man, I did stand up for
the first time. No, no, no, no.
Do you have any ideas or feedback how I
could work on that makes the mask you're
asking me to do right now.
I know once a week someone asks us that.
All of us that sends their first time
on stage, but I always still come.
I was like, don't you know the classic
advice is do it as much as you can. Do it.
Go anytime, go up anytime. You can
keep your eyes open to comedy around,
but I think essentially the best advice
to give a young comic is be cool to be
around, have fun, hang, get the
comics. We'd, when they come to town,
offered a drive them places just be,
don't be annoying, but like, hey,
if you need anything,
I'm your guy.
And just be cool because even if you're
a mediocre comic and there's better
comics than, than you that
are annoying, I will bring you
on the road as a mediocre
comic that you're a funny,
if you're a finance and then
by bringing on the road,
you'll get to be great because you'll
get more stage time. So it's like,
just be cool that and observe the fucking
etiquette of comedy. For instance,
if you're invited into
the headliners greenroom,
don't just bring your friends or your
girlfriend, mother fucking person.
Oh yeah, dive. We'll bring
like, what are you doing?
You're not invited a few friends with
them. I'm like, are you out of your mind?
This isn't yours. Yeah, no, that's,
that's your big one. I know you fucking
hate that. Or The chatty insane.
No Way. No, I emceed shows. I would never
be like, hey guys, come back with me.
And the would never occur to me.
I would never even stepped foot in the
green room without like, I'm sorry.
Can I do this? Yeah, I'm still
working in clubs. So it's like having,
you know the gray, you walk, you go to
a place in the green room is the author.
Oh, I've done, and I know you're
talking about grand rapids.
We were there together. I was just
thinking about you. The Bob, uh,
they're walking Hyenas Dallas hole.
That is,
you are the way,
literally fax going on,
but there's like still have fax.
Yes.
Oh yes. I lost my mind. Oh my God. Oh boy.
On the shot contest. So for people that
don't know, this was the crazy part too,
is that the MC goes up,
does 10,
the feature does 20 and kills.
And if you are headlining a show,
you go, I want to ride the wave.
Like this is what he's supposed to
do. He's setting up the show. They go,
all right. And you're like, all
right man. Great. Bring me up first.
We're going to do the blowjob
shot contracts, the craziest,
and then they brought a table on stage
setup shots brought up four people hands
behind their back, put your mouth over
the shot, hot back. All right. So I go,
hey man, could you not do that again
all weekend? And he's like, why?
And I was like, cause it's terrible
and I don't want to be a part of it.
And he's like, we always do it. I
go, I know, but I don't want anyone.
He's like, you're the only person that's
ever complained. I go, no, I'm not.
I'm the only person that's ever
complained to you. I go, everyone,
I'm sure it talks about it
and he's like, uh, I just,
I don't know why you're so upset about it.
I'm like,
because you're ruining the show.
I go, if you insist on doing it,
how about you do it between
the MC and the feature?
Kill the momentum of the
show. This guy was like, man,
you're really like fired up about this.
Then he brings in the other guy and
the guy's like, well, here's the,
here's why we do it.
And then you left because the
people who are doing their shots,
they each pay like 50 bucks to do that
to like be part of the show and do a shot
and so it, it pays for my MCC all
week. Someone I'm like, I don't care.
Hit
$50 a person. I'm like,
all right man. I go,
well I just want you to know how
much I hate that you do this.
And he's like, okay, all right.
Because he kept doing it.
They, they are so stuck in their ways and
when you ever try to inject like, Hey,
I do this for a living and
I had a different and other
places and I've seen the
way it works and it works
better when you do it this way.
Like something as simple as when
they start a show and they're like,
give it up for your, and like, are
you guys ready to have fun tonight?
Give it up for your headliner.
Nikki Glaser, first of all,
I don't like when they go, she's in the
building. Let her here, she's backstage.
I'm like, don't tell them where I am. You
can do better than that. Oh, I actually,
oh my God. I tell them to say
that I do. I tell the emcee, I go,
I'll get them to do a second
round because I, it's never like,
it's never not enough.
There it is. Like I like,
I like that you can do better
when I'm about to be brought up,
but in the beginning of the show,
before the MC ever comes up,
they go give it up for
your hedler Nikki Glaser.
Everyone thinks I'm coming to sage.
There's a huge applause, right?
Because a lot of people haven't been to
comedy shows, don't know how it works.
And then they go through the
whole roster and they go, yeah,
and you're featured act and it's like you,
they don't know who this is.
Stop acting.
A little shout out to our sponsor
is a Hampton Inn and the limo guy,
but it's just so awkward to sit across
from my feature in the green room who had
just heard crazy applause for my name
because that's who they came to see.
And then they have to put grudgingly
and then he already, he feels weird.
And so I've told them,
just can you just say the headliner,
but like they'll meet him. Have you
played the clubs where they prerecord it?
They, they have, they have the, uh,
headliners name recorded, but they
don't know who their MCS, so it'll go,
it's a prerecorded to go
and give it up for your Mc.
And that's it. The MCS, like
Emma and they walk up and they're like,
oh,
we didn't record your name and who
didn't know who because my God,
that's the only more horrible thing is
when they have the pre roll to the whole
event.
Now are you ready for this?
The clips from like Wayne's
world and you're like, I get it.
And there's like Billy Madison and
then mighty ducks. I'm like, yeah,
what are you pulling from? I have the
best one. There's two gray ones. Okay.
There's the comedy zone in Jacksonville,
Florida,
or it's brilliant down the twilight zone
theme and then the strobes. And then
there's lawyers,
20 people in a room when
you are not drawing.
And that kind of bombastic opening.
Yeah.
I can't see my Nachos. Yeah, we can
skip that tonight guy. There's 20 people
don't eat it. So my favorite by
far is when there's female act,
there's a side splitters
in Tampa, Bob, Bobby jewel,
and they,
they run a montage of women's
stripping and movies and they're like,
you can't leave. Y'All had
her home. That's the song.
And it's a montage like Demi Moore and
the stripper movie and this chick and
that chick stripping
and welcome to the stage Nikki Glaser.
And you're like,
they just saw a fucking montage of women
with their clothes off and now they're
expected to respect me telling them
jokes. Oh, have you ever, you're sober.
They s that I would hate that so much
because I hate being sexualized on stage
by the audience in any way. Worse. It
happens and usually it doesn't happen,
but anytime you take off your jacket it,
someone's going to know.
Even if a guy does it, I have
to say, but I will literally go,
I'm about to take off my jacket.
Will you guys please not go whoa,
like no one can. We all agree
to not, I just hate it a lot.
I just begged them and they can't not
do it. I love it. They can't not do it.
And then I feel weird because I feel like
I'm trying to be sexy and then I feel
like vulnerable in this way.
It makes you feel any better.
They do the same thing to me.
That's what I was going to say.
I think they do it to men too.
And because of the like to me when
they're doing it, they're like woo. Yeah.
Yeah. Anna, because of this podcast,
every time I take a sip of water, oh,
just a round of applause. Cause it
was the water champ of our fell. Yeah.
And that's bananas,
not the,
I actually enjoy that because I am the
Watertown inside joke, but yes. But yes,
and every show I go to, like even
in theaters they go like burns fat,
the yell it. Alright. Hey Larry Bear.
They yelled at at my shows to kind of say,
he's like,
oh they just, and racist cars.
You're comes barging in here.
Yeah,
right on time. Well done Bert. Thank
you very much. I'm feeling fantastic.
I hundred percent sober.
I know giving up drugs and
alcohol entirely and I'll
never go back and I believe
I'm supposed to introduce you as
the world's most racist comedic.
Thank you for sending that.
And I think that is a 98 uh,
FM and a Phoenix. Nice. Wow. I think and
he didn't thought that would be funny.
Really caught on.
And then he said that newspaper
right to get a call about and then,
and then what really
happened that made us like,
we just started blocking anyone that did.
It was can you just had to
because there's no fixing.
It was a news outlets started going.
What's the story here? It was a story.
Here's a follow me details.
I want to go live with this.
Okay.
Nothing more fun than torturing
everywhere. When I did radio,
when I was in a Philly, those, I
forget the Guy President Steve. Yeah.
They were like, what's up
with bird? You're like, well,
what's that?
That's really caught fire and happier
bird is the most racist fat comedian.
Okay.
Yeah. There you go. Hey,
really? Really? Yeah,
it's just glad that I'm glad it's getting
out. You know, because it's important.
You know the Louie stuff,
everyone was like,
we've always heard whispers of it and
now everyone knows we can all talk about
it.
This is the bird is fat and racist thing.
It's been whispered about for
years and now everyone knows.
It's kind of cool.
Hey
single right now we have a
lot of single men, suitors,
suitors.
Oh I need to get your take
and maybe what's working,
what's not,
who you're into,
who we could maybe connect you
with if you're interested. Yeah,
so I'll give you a few.
You tell me like turned on.
Do you want the number of digits?
Scale of one to 10 also want
the followup on Baguette.
I didn't forget last time you
told us about baggage. Oh,
why you said I have so much
to tell you guys. Okay,
well don't forget to tell us and that
bag as well. Bag It, you told us.
Here's what the story was.
The last story was this
baguette is a comic in New York.
That's your nickname for somebody and
you were like friends and you guys would
always like jokingly, I, you know,
kind of flirt and then you were like,
let's hook up. And then he made some
excuse or something and then you're like,
so what's up with that?
Like what was he thinking?
And then that's how we got
to know. We just, we just
guessed, we didn't know. Right.
I'm curious. You didn't know
that we've, that you don't
know the next step. No. Did,
nothing had happened with that though at
that point. At that point you were like,
he left me high and dry.
Okay. We hooked up. Ah,
then I hooked up and so,
okay.
This, it was, um, I, I was
so frustrated this night.
It was like one of the best
nights of my life, career wise.
And I was like the Belle of the ball.
And I'm at a party and he's there too.
And I'm like, we're both in a different
city and we're staying at the same hotel.
And I'm like, I look great,
greater than I will ever look.
I'm peaking that night and he's just
kind of like milling about the party and
we're making eye contact here and there
and being like, hey, you know, but it uh,
it just, he just was talking
to everyone else but me,
I'm sitting alone at this party.
It's tort near the end of the night and
there's this girl sitting next to me and,
and I'm like this, I was like, I that guy
over there, like we have been flirting,
I've like got a semi kind
of a Dick pic from him.
Things are happening and he will
not come talk to me. Like, look,
he's talking to some two guys that
he doesn't even know. I'm like,
what's going on? And she's like,
honey, if you can't get laid tonight,
none of us can.
I was like,
I know I'm wearing this dress
and like I'm dressed to the tens.
Like I'm just as cute as I can let,
I did TV that night.
Like it's impeded your hair
and done and do better.
And I was the Belle of the
ball for this thing that I did.
So like everyone at the party is
celebrating the things that I do.
It's like my words her, it's her Bat
Mitzvah. Yeah. It just felt like that,
you know, like, and I felt like the Prom
Queen Watch that tripod. I, oh gosh,
I gotta Watch the tread. Very. Um,
so finally we make eye contact
and I kind of give a look like,
what are you doing at this point? I've,
I've been bitching about him to this girl.
I'm all worked up and I'm like, I'm
done playing it. Cool. I just go, yeah,
I flag them in. I go
get him, come over here.
Any comes over. And I'm like, what are you
doing? And he's like, I don't know man.
I don't know. And then I'm
like, city or talk to me.
So we talked for like 20
minutes and then he's like,
I'm going to go and I'm like, I'm going
to go to, and I'm like, Oh my God,
I'm going to get like I'm about to go
hook up for the first time in like ever
like forever sober having like I'm going
to maybe like get laid tonight and it's
like going to be a one night thing and
it's just going to be fun. I was like,
yeah, and listen, I will add,
my rule for myself right now is not to
like bang people like I don't want to
have penises in my vagina because it
just get too attached and everything and
I'm sober and videos, but keep
going. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
So my rule is though and can always be
convinced if you get me worked up enough,
I'm going to be like, oh, we need to
bang right now. Right. The guys like,
let me just put the tip in and then
you're like, I'm suddenly like, okay,
like if I want to have sex,
I'm going to have sex,
but I just need to be convinced and boy
I can be convinced when I get horned up.
There's just, my brain doesn't
function like making logical choices.
I just want it real quick.
Yes.
A lot of men listen to this show
types of questions to get you.
Is it conversation? Should they,
is it like just great chemistry?
Do you point to anything in particular?
We have to have a little bit of a flirty,
flirty history. I'm like,
there's gotta be a little,
it's not going to be a one night thing.
There's going to be a little bit
of texting, flirting, going on,
and then in person play the long game.
Not Super Long,
but you have to acknowledge that
you are desperate to bang me.
I think that's just like,
I like nice things.
I like to feel women just want to feel
desired. Just make me feel like I,
there's something special about me that
you want me more than other people. Like,
even if it's a lie, just you know
what, just make me feel special.
Make girls feel like,
uh,
the woman in the long December
counting crows song all at all,
at once across a crowded room. You see
the way the light attaches to a girl,
like make me feel like I'm the girl in
the middle of a room that you just see
that's how girls want to feel.
Then in terms of like hooking
up to get to have sex with me,
we need more foreplay. And I feel
so cliche saying that as a woman.
Like I feel like a 90s lady,
like more foreplay honey.
Like it's almost like it's,
it just doesn't feel good to me to say
that, but it's, it just is true. Like we,
I need more. I just have a lot of times
guys going into soon where I'm like,
I'm not ready.
And that is the equivalent of like a girl
grabbing your limp Dick and being like,
come on and like you don't like,
like I'll let you know when I'm ready.
Just split. Let's dry hump, bring
back dry humping some over the genes.
Finger action. Right. There you go.
I'm no, no. As a mother of two busy,
I got a lot of shit on my roster.
I like to get in. I like to get out.
I like getting in and getting out too,
but when you're in my shoes though,
do you relate to like a little bit?
If I were a single gal, here's the
thing. As a mother of two young children,
the window for Gnocchi is so narrow.
Chubb,
it's like I know when it's coming
because I know we got it on the calendar.
We're going to do it tonight's the night,
so I'm thinking about it all day.
I'm like,
all right,
we're going to have I to put the kids
down and then I got this the window.
We've got to do it.
So I'm already thinking about it all day,
so when it's time go time, I'm like,
but even though let's pork, man,
let's fucking fuck.
I don't want to fuck around.
In defense of what you're saying,
yeah. I'll still be like, hey,
you want to warm it up a little bit?
You got to do what?
You have to warm up the oven
and, and, and I agree that's a,
that is nice to have someone who's
attentive to that kind of stuff. Yeah.
I just want to be begging you to put
yourself and make sure I don't want you to
be like, let's go and me go.
Okay. I want to be like bleed.
Sure. And um, and so I was hooking
up with this guy. We got back to,
we went back to our hotel,
we're on the same floor.
Our hotel rooms are back to back.
Wow.
Hotel rooms are right next to
each other. Perfect. I'm like,
I want to go to his because mine's a mess.
Like I like a slob on the road. Right.
Um, he's like, I have a buddy
staying with me and I'm like, oh man.
Like I want to look up, but I really, my
room is disgusting. And so I just am like,
give me a second,
let me go in and I'm throwing things now.
How disgusting do you get?
Like you leave the room service trays.
Are we talking coffee mugs and next to
the bed rappers in bed and stains on the
like cause I eat in bed so it just
looks like too, I get chocolate.
So it's like I'm shitting in bed, cross
town. I don't even flush the toilet.
Sometimes there's like p
and saving the environment,
leaving
on vacation, cleaned my
room, meet who, what's up
at the emotional
work week in a hotel.
It looks like there was a robbery,
possibly could have been multiple
salts in the room, like a shelter.
It looks like it should be on for
like 48 Frat guys live in there.
Take a photo for a magazine that is,
I relate to,
I haven't related to something more
and it really want them something so
specific and I tip wildly if you're
cleaning my room at the end of the week.
Yeah, me too. You're getting a lot.
Even when I was a contract I was like,
here's like, oh wait. Yes,
because it's gross to clean up.
And I tried to do a little good job
of tidying for the maid. But yeah,
and so I went in there and I missed a
couple of things. I think there was like,
uh, uh, my, I left like out my vibrator
type thing when he left. I was like,
ah, it was like our, and I'm sure he saw
it, but who cares now? And he's like,
we should put that in there. Let
me ask you something, when you,
if you travel with that,
is it in your checking bag or are you
doing a carry on with that in it? Um, it,
I don't have a vibrator.
I have this thing called the womanizer
and it like sucks your clit and so it
doesn't, if it turns on it's not going to
be an embarrassing sounds. What a name.
I don't like the way. No, it's the worst.
So can I make it something fun? You know,
women like Hello Kitty,
that's a huge thing. Yeah.
Hello Kitty vibrators because it
takes the nasty out of it. Any Nicer?
No, I know, I'm sorry.
So you put that in your carry on or
that goes in your throat checked.
But I would put it in my carry on button.
But no,
she ain't have no shame because if it
turns on, it's like very like if, yeah,
I don't care if someone says it looks
like an ear thermometer, say touches it,
that's not gonna. I would laugh.
I will actually enjoy that.
If a TSA agent had to open it up and be
like, ah, I'd be like, it sucks my clit.
Like I would just say that to his face.
Like very mad about faculty.
You just have a story out of it.
Same, same along the same lines.
I was traveling with my breast pump also.
Very sexy, very sexy, and I was like,
Oh God, what have Tsa opens it and touches
it with her fucking dirty. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. That is gross. Uh, check stuff.
You mean? No, carry on. Because it's a,
it's a device. It's sensitive devices.
Yeah. But even if you check it,
sometimes they rummage
through your bag and you know,
you get that note that's like,
I know because it's, yeah.
Yeah. I travel with my scrum master and
I lot of times I'll see them touch that.
Yeah. What do you travel? Do you
travel a scram? Master. Yeah.
Did you put it underneath and it goes
like right in your ass and then it comes
back up and the vibration goes around
the head. Kate. Okay, go ahead.
And is that a real thing? No.
Oh my God, it sounds great.
My Ass Brown.
The vibrator was,
you realize you love womanizer
and then we just start making out.
We get to work and um,
I have this new, I like,
I really am going to need to be
convinced before I do anything to him.
Like I'm getting,
I need to get some stuff done or at least
see the promise that something's good.
All right. So is this a, is
that etiquette? I'm never,
it's been a mess is a new rule for me.
He's got to give it away. So many Gotcha.
Comes like I've let so many guys come
when they haven't done anything for me
then I'm tired of it. Yeah. I'm 34
and I just, I don't believe, I don't,
just because I'm hooking up with a guy,
it doesn't mean he gets to come anymore.
And that used to be my role.
Like, you know, if you get two,
you get to a guy to a point where
he is thinking he's going to orgasm.
You a lot of girls feel obligated to
bring about that orgasm because there's
this blue balls thing and you
just feel like you're a bad woman.
He's going to be frustrated.
He's not to be able to get to sleep.
All these things,
like if he doesn't get to come,
and a lot of times you guys don't deserve
to come. You didn't do anything. Wow.
Two, um, and I love when you
come, I want you to come,
but if you're not even trying to make
me come at all, no desi very sided.
You don't get it. And guess what? Once you
calm, I know it's over. People are like,
well, just why don't you make him come
and then have them go down on you?
And I'm like, um, cause I don't
believe in animal cruelty.
I wouldn't make it a guy. I used to
say this, but like after a guy comes,
he wants to shut me like a laptop.
Like he doesn't want to like keep
fingering me. It's over. I'd be like,
have you ever been with a guy before?
That's not how it happened.
Girls say that though.
They don't know. But like,
but I feel that way too. Like after
the lady does Bangkok, I'm over it.
I'm like, oh good, can we, let's now see,
I am like still cause girls
can have like multiple,
so I can still be turned on enough
to like maybe I can go again. Sure.
That's true.
You need to kind of,
but I do relate to when you have
had one that's like the one time.
Yes. So I see related to that. So, so
you guys do it and so what happened? No.
So I'm, so we're looking up and
we're just making out and stuff,
but we're both really tired. Like really,
really like we've had long ass days.
We both worked and um, and his heart,
he's okay. I'm like almost naked.
I think. I'm just like wearing a
thong. Like that's it. And he's in,
he still has his shoes on and
like maybe a top hat. Like,
I didn't let him take off anything
because I was just like, you're,
I don't want you to think that you're
going to get anything out of this until
you at least do something for me.
And this guy definitely hasn't like put
in the work before and he's hasn't taken
me out. He hasn't done anything, really
isn't even a corded you at all at all.
So I'm just like, you had to
fuck your wave him. Oh over
fuck this guy. I like him.
So I just, and, and he's a nice
guy and he's so hot. God Damn it.
He's so hot. And so I was talking
and I'm like, why am I not turned on?
But I'm not, I just know that I'm
not going to have an orgasm. Like I,
the Wa the fingering style wasn't my
favorite, but that is not his fault.
He was doing a great job and he
was trying, but he was tired.
And also I've required like a lot of work,
like I'm a lot of work and that nothing's
been, sorry to interrupt, but yeah,
but nothing is worse than a bad
fingery. Yes, I can throw in.
You're not even close. No, and but I don't
expect someone to get that right. Yeah,
that that is beside. That's what
I like. See, we're all different.
I need to be like violently fracked.
Are you kidding me?
Well,
a lot of guys,
I mean eventually it leads to
mouth.
What do you mean into the mouth?
The Porno and then they choke
you with your own. Listen,
I'm not opposed to any of that stuff.
Eventually down the road,
the first time hookup,
so,
okay, so he's finger banging
you. It's not your style.
It's nothing against like I would,
I'm,
I can't wait to hook up with this guy
again because he has so much promise.
I just,
we were both tired.
His heart wasn't in it and at one
when I looked down and heart, not it,
it makes me crazy. It's knows I'm not
going to fuck him. He's pretty sure he's,
he's pretty sure. I'm like, I'm
really making them work for it.
Then he takes out his penis.
At one point I looked down and it's out,
which is reasonable. I was fully
like almost fully naked. Is sure.
It wasn't like I was like, oh no,
but his dick is out and I go, um,
thought it was oh yeah, it was, it was
great. It was good. Yeah. And I go,
um,
you're going to need to put that away.
Like it's not going to be addressed yet.
Like I'll let you know, but it's not now.
So I made him put it away.
I don't like,
I actually like to be the one dominated,
so I did not like doing that. Yeah.
She's just like put that away.
I know like the Puerto Rican guide that
I thought would be my one night stand,
it was a similar thing where I was like,
no, I don't think so. And to say no,
and you're right,
the pressure is very high on us to
continue with what you're doing.
And it's really, it's hard
to be like, Nah, that was
harder for me to do that anal,
I got to put away his deck when I
was like, I'm just not, I don't want,
I want it yet. I'll let you
know. That's very mature.
This is what I want to know.
How did he handle that?
That's true. He goes, oh,
he was, he was like really?
Like he was kind of like really
like he couldn't believe it.
That was going to be put away,
but he was understanding this guy was so
cool about all of this stuff. So cool.
Great Guy. That's why I'm like, I really
do like this guy. And I even told him,
I was like,
listen,
you have a great deck and I can't wait
for this thing to be in me someday and it
will be if you play your cards right, like
I'm, I'm looking very forward to that,
but it's,
it's just not tonight and I'm not even
convinced I'm going to like deal with it
tonight. Like I might not even
touch it because first of all,
I don't have that much confidence
in the end at this point.
Surely like four months ago or
whenever this one's five months ago.
I've gotten way better at blow jobs since
then, but at this point I'm just like,
those aren't, I'm not really like
confident enough to be like, well,
let me just do this and not competent
enough to enjoy doing it. Well,
I mean that's kind of a
special treat for somebody.
I always felt that that
believing that a guy,
a blow job is harder than
just being like just fucking,
that's why I know Christine that is weight
struggle is because I always just go
to sex because it was so much easy.
It's the easiest thing,
but for some reason it has the most
weight attached to all your mouth is so
intimate and really commit the Lakers,
which were would you go mouth first?
What are you talking about?
What's which one? All of them
after a game. They're clean.
They're showered.
Babe.
I would much rather just get banged out
a bunch because at least you're getting
something out of that. I don't have like
that's what I'm endings in my mouth.
It's actually very uncomfortable.
That's when I'm giving a
blowjob to someone I love
and care about. It's amazing.
It's so fun to do, but, or it
can be, it's not, but it can be
put it away. So cool about it. And then
do you end up,
you go back
and then I think it takes, he takes,
he took it out again. I think you can.
I know which is again fine cause we were
really working up to some stuff and I
just, it was a mixture of me being like
you don't deserve it. And also, um,
I don't really want to do anything to you.
Like I'm not in the mood to suck a penis
and I certainly am not in the mood to
Jerky was like I have no jerk off coffee.
I don't do that and neither do I.
So I'm not going to do things I'm not
good at and so I'm just not going to do
anything to you.
And so I kind of,
at one point we were just like making
out and it was kind of just get winding
down, you know, and I, we
just kind of go and he goes,
do you just want to go to our separate
hotel rooms and jerk off to this?
And I was like, yes, he gets up,
doesn't have to put on anything cause he
has everything on. He kisses me, goodbye,
leaves any walks and I hear him go into
his room and we both just standards.
I don't know if he jerked off, I
just ate some chips and watched, uh,
in my feelings challenges the
Drake and my feeling like that was,
I remember it was the night I saw
Kiki, do you love me? And I was like,
what is this dance craze? And I just
watched it in bed and I was like, oh yeah,
I just hooked up to, it was weird. So that
was the end of it. And um, since then we,
we sext and stuff and we see each other
out and about and there's like so much
fun.
NRG and it's still
still very much on still alive.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Well, guess what?
There's a little competition for baguette
letting some of your mom's house might
soon be in Nikki's pants.
If you play your cards right.
Here we go, whew, man. My fucking
with clown. Look, I'm from Florida.
I'm looking for my queen. No, I'm saying
Sean Garby skin shown Barbie Fitch.
You can be anywhere between,
you know what I'm saying?
I just need some man motherfucking Wiki.
Juggle that low.
You know what I'm saying?
Well guys, this is, she doesn't
have to be fat or skinny,
but she has to be a juggle at.
Yeah.
Are you into ICP or kind of know?
I know you that well.
I don't feel like he really sees
me. Okay. You know what I mean?
What I know don't feel seen.
Fair enough.
Do you see his lack of teeth?
What do you think about
those fake shoppers?
Okay. I've been on here.
I've been polite. A bank.
Yeah. I like to house. Right on Natalie.
Ups I would like
to do is you read lefties.
I would like to have some sex.
Okay.
Those are three different things,
but also just some
probably appealed to you.
I like to have a woman in my home.
I can make her laugh. I must throw
out quite one. These young men are,
these little boys. They get
their set us off and then, oops,
they don't care about their partner.
He's talking about,
okay.
Oh last,
Ooh.
Ghoulish I asked lady,
hey blue band, make sure
you, I even, I so yeah,
Mickey's face, he says, oh,
cause it's in my memory forever.
It's almost a threat.
Let me know what I just noticed too.
Ladies. I would like to pass.
I want to have sex. I got it.
This is Asmar rabbi.
Yeah, tell me about it. We
weren't, weren't fascinated.
I love it so much that people are ASR
sensitive, right? Yeah. Like you, it's,
yeah, it's tell people what it is. Okay.
So it's auto sensory Meridian
response I think is the ASM or,
but it's this feeling that you get
when you hear, um, there's certain,
uh,
sound stimuli that make
you feel a tingling in the
back of your head that kind
of goes down your spine and
gives you this really soothing,
like numbed out wonderful feeling that
is described as brain a brain orgasm,
but it's not sexual. It just feels
super relaxing. Like, you know,
that thing you put on your
head that I love bangles.
It's like that everywhere
and it's more intense.
And people that have it have been
getting it since they were kids. Like,
I didn't know. Head thing is
my, Oh my God, it's so amazing.
Just get another one of those.
I know everyone should have one of those.
Why doesn't everyone have, we used
to, it's good writers. I hope that,
oh, I don't like that. I
don't like that. No. Okay.
I like soft spoken and I'm
like whisper. Oh, what about,
oh yeah, I like this. I
watched people eat a lot.
Oh yeah. What does a cereal
salad. There's a salad. Yeah,
I think he's you like to this does that
for you. You feel the tingle, right?
Yeah. I love this. I know it's,
there's too many mouth sounds.
I don't like that. Oh it's two girls
just go into town. Is this a Muck Bang?
That's what they call this when people
just eat a discuss like the sound though.
I just, yes. Wow. Yeah.
Actually I don't like the girl on the
left cause she's cheating with her mouth
closed. I kind of like an open
mouth and I know that disgusting.
I didn't realize this until I was on a
plane once in a girl was eating a bag of
sun chips next to me and I was getting
numbed out so hard because this is a
feeling I've been getting since I
can trace it back to my first time.
I felt it was in kindergarten and my
school teacher was reading a book to the
class and just the way she turned the
pages and was reading it and then she
would show it to all of us like this and
I would just be like, good, good, good,
good. Don't stop. Don't
stop. Like it would be like,
or the kind of orgasmic type feeling,
but not, it wasn't like it was turned on.
You don't get wet listening to these
videos. You just feel so God damn,
I thought I was gay for a while because
it's always women's voices that do it
for me. So throughout my childhood it
would just be like, you know, uh, uh,
a woman like a mob who was volunteering
with our math class to like help us with
our homework and she would reach around
me and um, and, and show me like,
you carry the seven and then you add the
three bracelets with like jingle on the
desk. And I couldn't even
pay it. I would just be like,
oh,
it was so good.
But now I've worn it out so much that
I don't even get the tingles anymore.
It just is soothing to me to
play these videos. This guy,
this guy's a SMR guy here.
Hey guys,
I'm going to tell you something.
You are not bad.
Nothing is bad.
It's a matter of the
physical life on them.
I hate what he's saying, but I
like his voice. Do? Yeah. Yeah.
Can we face
our penis?
Oh No. Let's see. 10 o'clock no,
his teeth are so crooked, but so
white. Oh, I guess the other DNA.
Wait for someone with
that crooked of teeth.
You wouldn't think I care about whitening.
Sure. Yeah. This could be natural white.
I don't know. No sulfur. I don't know.
What makes you to know it
makes teeth white, by the way,
when I notice on the ALMAC ECOM guy is
that he often does videos without his
teeth.
However,
on this last video you'll notice that
he took the effort to put in his bottom
bottom teeth and not and
not the top, however. Oh,
so he kind of half ass the
denture game. It's like, well,
if you're going to go half, yes.
Why not put the top ones into? Yeah.
It was an interesting choice on his
part and makes for a really good why mh
video.
He checks all the boxes.
You see a bad lighting,
bad background,
denture choices, bad
request. It's all there.
If I have another one of
his, cause I know. Sure.
I got legitimately excited that you had
an actual people. No for me to consider.
Now there's, you really are, I mean,
we're all friends. The same people.
Which comedian do you want a date?
Because we all know that I've been through
them all or all the ones I want right
at this point. Yeah, I know. I know.
Why are you going to, are you open?
Are you open to, hey, you know we have
data comedians. Do you? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm open to comedians. I think
I'll end up with someone. Um,
who's a comedian or like at
least is a narcissist. Oh look.
Bare minimum. Yeah. Do you think
you are in our sister? Probably.
I don't think so a little bit, but I'm
drawn to narcissists I've found. Oh,
you like the emotional unavailability.
You like musicians? No,
never really. I mean, yeah,
optically they are pleasing,
but I've never really had a connection
with one where I'm like, okay,
okay,
because here we go, here we go. I have
another beat down for your child practice,
practice my own songs is my introduction
to my song coming out. You're,
here we go. I'll sing it. She's
worth the machine's worth.
Then they got a gun and got again.
Yeah. Got to terminate her gun. Yeah.
Machines.
But the machines were thin tea,
16 to 60 to 6100% to 16 machines with
thin or students with thin trying to wreck
my rep, trying to make my rough talk
to summit flow, trying to practice.
Some are full,
no street. I don't care. But the haters,
the haters.
Hey, that's a great attitude. I thought
he was saying machines worth it. Oh No.
Within yeah. Machines with
them. Machines within. Um,
yeah, I'll consider it. Yeah. Um,
are you aware of this man?
Uh,
who reached out to a lady,
I mean,
picture yourself leaving the gym and
somebody calls your name after like,
Hey Nikki and you don't know them.
Yeah.
And then this is the scenario of how this
actually happened. If you don't know.
So this young lady left the gym.
Somebody says her name,
Hey Nikki, like do I know you?
And the guy was like, I just,
I saw your name on the sign in sheet.
Oh. He's like, well, you're lovable.
You're beautiful. You know, I'd love
to take you out sometime. You're like,
I'm just, and you do like the kind
put that like where you're like,
I'm actually talking to my ex and
um, you know, we're just kind of,
and he's like,
what can I get your number and you're
holding your phone so you're like, I,
you know what? I'll take your number this
way if I want to. And then you're like,
put your number in there and he puts
his number in there and then he dials.
So now he has your number and then he has,
since he has your number,
you think that's that you're
like, all right, whatever.
The next morning you wake up
and this is on your phone.
Good Morning Julia [inaudible] Gel.
Just wanted to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that meeting you yesterday and
getting a look at you was part of one of
the greatest moments of my life.
You were so beautiful.
You don't know how beautiful you are
to me. I mean just, you're gorgeous,
you're precious. But it's been sitting
in my mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with
your ex boyfriend, please
erase him from your memory.
Don't ever go back in the past.
I know,
cause I've been there and I understand
when you know you're trying to find
somebody and you go on dates,
nothing compares to your Eurex,
but there is that better
person out there and Julia,
I promise you it is me. I will love you
like you've never been loved before.
Day One, minute one, I'll make you
feel like a woman, a real woman,
and believe me,
after you experienced me,
you won't even know who
your ex boyfriend is.
Open up your heart to me in your arms.
Let's go full throttle.
I could see me fall in love with you.
It just so I don't know. I just looked
into your eyes and I just melt. Anyhow,
I've had an off to work.
This is my cute little home.
Everything you see behind me,
I built everything every square inch
from crown mold and the chair rail to
floors, to lighting, to
plumbing, doors, windows.
So this is the type of guy. Again,
I'm a very handy guy and uh,
I love to build you. Whatever you want.
You're a sweetheart. Hold on. Wait for it.
Wait for it. Video doesn't scare you,
but that's how I feel. Wait for it.
I just want you to know that.
Okay. And I look forward.
I'm going out to dinner with
you so let's make it happen.
Nah,
Ciao Baby.
Sorry. Just to kind of thing
you're talking about foreplay wise,
I mean he kind of was like making her
field desire. Yeah. Things that I was,
oh Nikki, do we have a love
connection here? I'm just,
I feel bad that I've missed if I've
misled anyone to think that that would be
appropriate because that was so gross.
But also he goes upstairs.
Sorry if I scared you.
Had some self awareness that I kind of
appreciated at the end of the Ma was kind
of silly and like a fun, I
liked it. I didn't hate it.
See them walk a few more times,
but he's kind of being funny.
Like he had his little sense of humor.
Like,
I don't know that he was trying to
be completely sincere. Wait a second,
where did you get this and what
is, why is this real? It's so real.
And were friends with
Julia now. Yeah. And she,
so we found this will sign to us first.
We found the story out.
We are fans contacted Julia,
we talked to Julia and then she sent us a,
why am age exclusive?
There's a second one that he said she did
not respond to the first you I want to
say good morning. You send her
that at all. Yeah, my flower,
my precious.
I still to be my everything.
Have a great day. Love. Oh wait,
it's his signature. Yeah, it's, that's,
that is so disgusting.
And you know,
discuss what is going on with this
guy. What, how does he have a house?
He builds them.
But I just,
this crazy person like have a job in
a house and like a gym membership.
I don't understand how these people live.
I live in Longmont lesson
has had a lot of fun with it.
Julia
that morning,
let's know that this car here that
I'm driving. Yeah, I built it myself.
I fixing the heating. The heating
didn't work when I got the call,
but it's like I'm really
handy so I was able to fix it.
You told me all about you and I just
wanted to let me know that I have full
approval on look,
get all the fans
a pot.
Oh boy.
Good Morning Julia.
Good morning.
Julia,
you so much.
I've been thinking about you
every day or do anything.
I wanted to get you something.
Only women can really fully appreciate
like the uncomfortable creepiness and
attack mode of receiving that message.
Guys do it. It's very funny too,
but I feel like the women doing it,
it's kind of
the women capture the feeling.
I contact.
I catch with dog named.
Uh,
that's right.
I named after you so anytime you're not
here I can just come out and say good
morning Julie.
That's pretty great. Oh Man, we've all
been Julia before where? Just Nice.
She'd give him your phone.
Then how can you go?
How did this guy get my number?
How did it get to this Rick?
To me
when we first saw these,
his video, I was like,
I actually felt bad for the guy a
little bit. Have we traced, well we've,
we've got some,
I'm kind of don't want to,
let's not. Yeah, yeah. Don't,
don't learn. No, this guy's scary.
But the thing was that
like I started to go like,
well I feel like what he
did was he didn't control,
there's an impulse in
you to not send that.
But like you meet somebody, right? And
you go like, oh my God, I want that.
That's my everything. It's like a
a rush, but everything in you goes,
well don't you don't make a video
to scent. Like sometimes you send,
maybe you sent a text to somebody,
like I feel like an idiot. Right?
You send it text,
but to make a video like,
so I felt bad for him that
he put that out there.
But at the same time there's
something real wrong.
There's something wrong.
There's a sadness about his situation.
Yes. Oh, I don't even know that.
I want to make fun of this.
Cause this guy maybe a special,
but then he built that whole house.
He can't be that like he's not special.
You're not touched.
It feels a little touch.
That lack of awareness.
[inaudible]
and Julia, I just wanted to tell you
that getting it's been my anniversary
with you the other day. It was one
of the greatest moments in my life.
Life.
Anyway, all uh, I'll hop off
here but have a good day baby.
Oh, they always the fans.
Julia. So many fans. Juliet.
I'm so excited.
I can hardly contain it.
I don't know if you recognize
this, but I'm in the class. It,
I bet friend
restraints.
Ah,
I heard you coming in through the front
door now to change the locks back on
your door.
That's a lot of stuff I could be fixing
was great. One. Can't wait.
We'll all end up going to cough.
So fucking full truck
anyways,
I'll see you in a second.
Yeah, there's so many of them.
They did so many funny ones.
And then today we already did it twice.
But should we play it for Nikki because
it's so good. It's so good. Dude.
We have this guy who does prank
calls. Yeah. For us with the show.
Oh my God, this is, I think his
masterpiece. Like I've never,
it's the best thing I've ever heard.
Um,
he right. It's like, it's,
it's unbelievable. It's genius.
So this guy called,
um,
he called a hardware store
and he sets up a call.
He sets up the drops he's going to play.
So he calls the hardware store
that's taking applications and he,
hello, this is Kevin, the
store manager. May I help you?
Hey Kevin. My name is Bert
called in regards from my father,
her the harder and so,
uh,
my dad's been a handyman 35 years now.
Oh, okay. What's Your Dad's name?
Heroin will puts you on the phone.
Maybe you can just tell them a little
bit more about the job. His name's Joe.
Oh, okay. Awesome. Okay.
The morning. Me, Joe.
Hello Joe. I'm a very handy
guy. Just wanting to say,
I built everything every square inch
from crown mold into chair rail.
Perfect. Yeah. The floors to
lighting, to plumbing doors,
windows installed.
This is the type of guy you got
to build you whatever you want.
I just want you to know that,
hey, let's make it happen.
Um,
so
you're hard to make in your arms.
How beautiful you are to me.
Yes. I mean just, you're
gorgeous. You're precious.
I will cherish shoes turned into that
love you like you never been loved before.
Uh, uh, come in and read heart. Okay.
Okay. I look forward going
out to dinner with you.
Come in and see he and easy handling
all the incoming and outgoing.
I could see me falling in love with you
anyhow. I'll make you feel like a woman.
A real one. Okay. Ciao baby.
I'll make you feel like a real woman.
Okay, Joe. Okay. Joe. Jesus Christ.
It's so juveniles. That one
fucking amazing saw. Amazing.
Oh No. Nikki, have you ever
done the converse of this?
Like have you ever sent something that
you wish you had it to a boy where you
wish like, oh my God, time. Uh,
but the text messages? No, I mean,
yeah. Um, I've seen
like pictures and stuff,
but I really am pretty good about like,
if, if I send you a naked picture,
like you, I trust you a lot.
Like it takes me a lot to that.
Oh No. And I want to, man, it's
like sometimes I'm like, God,
I can't do anything with,
like sometimes you get out of
the shower and you're like,
I work on myself and I'm like,
I'm, I'm peaking right now. Oh,
I know what you're like, say
the opposite. I'm like, Ooh,
I don't know why to look at a lighting.
I'd have to get on myself. God Damn it.
Somebody would throw
up if I sent him this.
I don't think anybody wants to look
at my mom's sloppers either. Well,
I've said I have many days like that,
but like there are some
days where you're like,
I wish I could share this with someone,
but I just don't.
And I know a lot of girls that will just
send those things out to get validation
and praise all angels.
I know you don't know.
And so many things like that. But,
um, I can't do it, but I've sent,
I'm just like,
I've had manic episode,
like where I'm just having a bad day and
I'm mad at a guy or something and then
I just am like, well, I don't
think you understand where
I'm coming. Like, you know,
you just have a text exchange. I'm home
for Thanksgiving and having a manic.
And then you look at a bunch of,
of chunk of blue and you're like,
I didn't need to send the same graph right
back a little while to this stuff. But
do you ever do it? Like I was always,
I was never, I didn't like, um,
like if I went out on a date with
a girl and then like, uh, you know,
it was a good date. You're like,
I like her, you know, I like her,
but then she's like, oh, I can't stop
thinking about you. I go like, ah,
no, that's, yeah, she's like gross. Yeah,
it's a lot. It's a lie. I would be like,
that's weird. And then I don't know,
suddenly I tell a friend,
some people react differently.
So like some friends would be like,
it's great, right? I'm like, no, no,
but she's talking about it. We went
on a date. Yeah, I play it. Cool.
I always like, well don't you remember
being in like six or seventh grade?
Like just when the feelings start to
really get intense. That's the opposite.
That's what Joe did. Joe Did
a sixth grade, right? Yes.
I want to love you forever
and I'll be your everything.
I felt the way Joe's felt recently
when I know that I shouldn't,
you know, you let your mind
wonder and it was like this is,
I would be there for it. Like I don't
know, happens in you when you do not let,
you don't even let out one percentage
of what he let out. You play it. Cool.
And I remember being in seventh grade
and just being so obsessed with this boy
in my class. Like, you know
when you're just, Oh my God,
but you don't really like I was in
seventh grade, so at that level,
I mean there was like one girl
that had been finger bang,
our went on to say her name,
but she had really big cans
and so everybody assumed
that she was a slut and I
don't think she was,
her first name is Shelby and that they
said that she got fingered during top gun
at the movies.
I don't think it happened,
but the point is I was so into this
guy and you know, you're just like, oh,
I just burning with love. And I would
just like write letters and be like, Gosh,
I give a talk and I thank God I didn't.
But you know what I mean?
When you're like this close to doing
that thing and you're like, Oh God,
I just should,
I should convince yourself even as
like I'm not like in the past couple of
years, like you just go to a place where
you can convince yourself that, I mean I,
I'm constantly having to play games
with guys with texting and exhausting
acting. Like you don't want to hear from
them when you do and not watching their
Instagram videos so that they know
that you don't really care about that.
Like it's there so people can
tell if you've watched. Yes, yes.
Huge thing. Like your Instagram
story. Okay. So like if you look at,
you can look at your own Instagram story,
swipe up on it,
and then you see everyone
who has watched it.
Now if you have a crush on a guy and a
guy likes you a way he can let you know
he likes you before you even talk is
that you just start seeing his name under
everything that you do and you're like,
he's paying attention to me, this guy.
And then you go, okay, this guy in to me.
And then maybe you start following him
or maybe like you the next time you see
him at the club or whatever you're like,
and you just,
that is a way to let a girl know that
you're in tour is if you want a lot of
soul. And it's a way to let
someone know your nodded to them.
If you are continually
watching each other's videos
and then all of a sudden you
stop seeing his name, you go, oh my God,
he doesn't even care about me anymore.
When a lot of times they're purposely
not watching it so that they can send so
that they can play it cool.
Which I've done before where I'm like,
I'm not gonna Watch this stuff so that
he doesn't think that I'm thinking about
his career.
So it's,
so why aren't you stoked that we hooked
up on the time of like Friendster.
Friendster was around when
Tom and I got together.
This is craziness and that's
when I just go, you know what?
I'm going to stop playing these games
and just be honest and say how I feel.
And then that's not good either.
So you,
it's either you play games or you're,
you scare them off with your honesty.
So it's just, it's, it's
too complicated. What Jean
has beautiful teeth,
perfect teeth, very white.
Do you get them professionally whitened?
No. You know what I use? Um, I turned on.
All I do is I use arm and hammer baking
soda went through too is all you did.
And I'm not kidding you guys.
Mama's secret. That's what you do.
What are you guys using? No, I'm saying
that's like old school, like doing it.
Arm and Hammer. Baking soda whitening
toothpaste. I've turned everyone on to it.
Anyone who does it,
just brush with that regularly in your
teeth will be white and you'll get
compliments about it.
That's all I do.
Get some on Amazon right now using our
banner. Go to your mom's house, podcast.
Com. Click on the banner
at the bottom of that page.
Do Your shopping as you normally
would. Wow. You have great teeth. I,
I'm really nice teeth. Thanks.
Got Invisalign happening lately.
I snored a while. I have a
snore guard type. Guess what?
My wife snores now.
Uh,
if you go to Instagram and go on my page
so your guys are so funny with them.
Oh my God, Christina snore. You're such a
jerk. He just brought that up right now.
You know what's crazy? I have a
library of them stored so that, oh,
so don't feel safe. Don't
even feel safe. A library.
What did you just say? Well, there's
different snores in different days.
You know why she never
snored before she snored?
You're fucking evil during you are a
sociopath. You're going to murder me guys.
This is evidence for everybody listening.
Not going to murder. This is evidence.
Your psycho mother of my children, he
was something about anal sex. Negative.
Wait a minute. You've been collecting
footage of me snoring since that.
Since we first blasted.
He just a few weeks of it.
She's Oh no.
Oh No.
There might be a montage
coming. I don't know. No,
no. I don't know. Are you fucking
kidding me? I don't know what's happened.
Please promise me though.
People aren't looking at my tits out and
stuff cause I sleep, you know, come on.
It's only the guys who want looking
at bay clipper, Lake Racers.
I had a dream that night that Tom and I
were doing it and that it was directly,
it was the night we went to a Lakers.
He saw a lake and as we started to go
to a Lakers game, next morning I go,
I was dreaming. We're making sweet marital
love and that he was all his color.
Yeah. Tom Colored. Yeah, but
his Dong was a big black dog.
How'd you feel about that?
I was like,
cool and I'd love to go
to another Laker game.
I Dunno why I'm really drawn
to these things now. Ever
like sports. She was like,
these Laker games are a blast. How's
that? Okay. I was like, how bad?
She was like, I mean they're fun. Can
we, when's it going to go to another one?
All right. Okay. I told
my therapist about it.
You get home immediately and
taking Melatonin. You're like,
I need to get to dreamland
right away.
Right away.
And then like during the game,
just like how big do you think their
dicks are? Probably pretty big.
I did not ask you that after the
game. You're like, Nah. You're like,
how come they're dicks and balls aren't
like fluttering the show when we were
talking about after my dream,
it was a good way of compression
shorts on a good question.
I could just be a dick and ball festival.
I don't know how you guys keep it all
but yeah, they have a bigger problem
than I do that you are a straight
sociopath. What did I do?
You're keeping videos
of your wife's snoring.
I cannot fucking believe
you're doing this.
You're actually going to have a whole lot.
I have 15 it's not like I have a,
well so uh,
Victoria Wiggins has a youtube channel
and she's helping people prep with anal
sex. We have our anal sex
expert, Nikki Glaser. Oh God.
Blow us all away. Last time I
haven't had it since last time.
I don't think really want to tell me
what you think of Victoria's advice gave
advice and we want to know and I actually
kind of want somebody else in the room
to maybe pay attention to.
A lot of people have been asking me,
Victoria,
I'm so scared to have,
dare I say having sex in your
bus can be extremely terrifying.
There's a lot of things that
could go wrong, but when you,
there's a lot of things that could
go right. I've got a few tips.
First is what you need. It's all about
your diet and start in the kitchen.
That's what they say, right? Well,
same thing goes for bottoming.
It starts in the kitchen.
There's a lot of things that you can't
eat like a few days before you bought
them.
So like pizza through vegetables,
any food, any kind of protein, carb,
fat. This is all food. What
should we eat? I'm not a few tips.
First is what you eat. It's all about
your diet. Abs Start in the kitchen.
That's what they say, right?
Step two, you got to relax.
When Tony going in there,
you're immediate reaction.
If you're new to the,
to the bus scene,
just clinch and you being your
body registers it as poop.
So your immediate reaction is just clench
it out cause that's what you've done
your whole life.
Well,
I'm here to tell you that you're
going to have to unlearn that.
I always start by letting me know
that I need him to start off slow.
I need him to go gradual.
I need him to go easy because you
don't want to start out too strong.
That's going to expedite your body's
immediate reaction to push out things.
I don't think we're intended to go up
there. However it feels really good.
So maybe there was a master
plan. I'm not sure. Jesus,
if you're out there loving the most,
you might clench so hard.
You might bleed through the sheets.
I mean,
it's happened to me before
and it's not a fun experience.
You could also be in a situation where
your body hates it so much that it will
shit on them.
Even though you've cleaned yourself out,
even though you didn't eat for three days,
it'll still shit on them because
it's like, it's like a kind of like,
it's like get away from me.
Not Eat for three days.
Is that what she's suggesting?
That is what she's doing.
And I know girls that are like,
oh, I might have anal sex tonight.
I'm not going to eat today,
will not give you that. But I didn't
really, I'd say that's sound advice.
I would just like to maybe in the next
time I have it,
I'm do I have like a whole plan?
Because in the past it's been like
impromptu and I've been lucky.
I've also been unlucky,
but like in the future if I like
want it and I'm going to go do it,
I'm going to get a, um, I'm going to,
cause I've done enemas like before
because you're supposed to just squirt,
went up there and clear it all out.
But I don't know if I
talked about this last time,
but like you have to get like 10 enemas.
You can,
what do you tell them in 10 of us to be
totally thing you need to do it until
the water runs clear.
Oh.
And I bought one once and that just
mixes things up and makes everything,
oh, I see. What's bad, bad news.
And I, and I remember being like,
I'm so sorry that happened.
Literally that happened because I
was trying to actually be better.
Like you know that that was so much worse.
So there's ones I have,
I'm a hairstylist who is a gay
man and he was like, oh honey,
you need to get off Amazon like a reusable
one that you just keep filling with
saline solution instead of buying
like 16 bucks enemas at Walgreens.
It's smart. It's a lot of work, but it's,
it feels really good and it's worth it.
I think it's when I am in the mood to
have some like really amped up like dirty,
dirty sax and like really go all
out. Um, yeah, I put in that effort.
Wow Man, this word, this pay
attention. What about now?
I just had my second
child five months ago.
So there's a lot of damage down there.
We're still,
what do you do if a cow has hemorrhoids?
Cause I still, you're not doing that.
I can't have bud sex. How did you
know that way? Did you hear that?
Hemorrhoids are so painful. I'm so sorry.
Oh, no, it doesn't hurt me as hard.
It kind of doesn't. It's
weird. I don't know if it's,
cause I have a lot of fiber and my dad,
I don't push a lot when I make brown. Oh,
that's not really bothering me, but I
don't know if I'm going in at my, yeah.
Upset it. I just wouldn't want to. I think
the tissue is too sensitive for that,
but um, but yeah, it's like,
like she's saying about, um,
your body like pushes it like it,
it thinks it's poop.
Like that's a real,
I believe that because I've done a
suppository once and the how that works,
I believe there's glycerin too,
is that it's actually because you're
introducing something into your butt that
makes you feel like you have to shit.
Do you understand? Like, you know,
you can get a baby to take a dump is if
you stimulate his be whole with the qtip
that actually just stimulating
Massell think that it's already,
there's something right at the precipice
because a lot of times that's when it's
like, get out, get up. Right.
Sure. That was her next suggestion.
Next we're going to talk about animals.
I think animals are the best way
to prep yourself in a life packs.
You can buy enemas at the
drug store, Walmart, target,
wherever they have like a medicine I'll
obviously you want to get on the floor
on all fours
and then poke your ass up in the air.
Kind of like you're about to have sex.
It's kind of like a practice round.
You get your head down ass up just like
taiga likes it and you stick that in.
You squirt in all the liquid.
You don't want to do it too fast because
it can really disrupt the lining of
your bus. And then when I actually
like to do kind of bounce around,
maybe like, oh, okay,
I've never seen this actually helpful
just to kind of mix everything.
When your stomach starts hurting, when
you help all that fluid inside of you,
that's a good thing because that means
that you're ready for the grand finale.
The release, you need to sit on
the toilet for like 10 minutes.
You don't want to like squirt it out,
do your little Squirtle move
and then go hop on Daddy's Dick.
That's not how it works.
You want to go sit pro tip.
If you do feel like you need to do
around to please just use another enema.
Do not refill the bottle of water.
I don't know what's in that shit,
but something in that solution
that's a not bottle really works.
Water water will make your asshole rar.
Then at the end of it,
I mean it's just not good.
Oh Man.
My pet peeve is when people say their
stomach hurts and then you shit.
It's not your stomach that's hurting.
It's your intestines.
Your stomach is an Oregon above your
and test it. It's been my pet peeve.
My entire for my tummy hurts. It's not
your tummy stupid cause your intestines,
your stomach,
the stomach's different pain and it's
the same thing like when women are
pregnant it's like it's none of my
stomach. Tommy. Does your tummy,
the babies in your tummy? No, not.
Do you know how bodies
were right to your uterus,
your cut button?
My upper,
my fucking cut.
She keeps saying her bus,
nine times out of 10,
if he's going to fuck your house,
he's going to eat your ass better.
Taste good.
You don't want to be tasting like
true mixture of shit and animals.
Baby. Why so much even? I'm like,
I can't so much never happened.
You want to act like you weren't just in
the bathroom after doing those animus.
Yeah. You're gonna feel like you need
to shit more. Sure. Times out of 10,
it's false. It's a trick.
If you do two animals,
you're not going to shit. And I don't
know why we're not all doing it.
There's a lot of websites that
say, oh, you enemas are good,
but they're not necessary.
Sometimes all you need is a,
a soapy finger and a
washcloth. Well, I'm sorry,
are we living in the fucking 16 hundreds?
Do we not have enemas?
That's what they're made for.
Oh my God, you guys are so
disgusting. Um, all right,
well thanks for the advice Victoria. If
you want to donate, but Victoria, uh,
like to donate, uh,
raising money for surgery,
go from me.com/victoria
f f s is what I think I see
here. Yeah. So there you go.
Yeah. Um, well it's a lot of
advice. I learned some stuff,
some stuff you should it to two of us and
if you have to shit after that is 900,
seven times. It's an illusion. It looks,
sounds like she's saying you might want
to get that box from rite aid of all
those. I think I'll get three
next time I'm ready to go.
But then I got to buy them separately
because I don't want it to look like I'm
about to have anal sex. You let me
ask you this, Jeff, do Yada Yada.
I have a question for you.
It just seems like studies so much work
to prepare for anal and doesn't it?
I just imagine after giving
myself three or four enemas,
I've killed the mood cause I
been shitting all day. Yeah.
You know when you have diarrhea
and then later you're like,
I can't have sex tonight. I
just shit a lot today. You know,
sometimes Tom will have diarrhea and
I'll be like, are we still doing it?
And you're like, no, I just had diarrhea.
Diarrhea is no plant leg
while you're shitting all day.
You just said isn't it make your be whole
soar to give so many animals and then
you know. But I think in giving yourself
animas it would feel kind of good.
Like if you're in the
anal sex like as a girl,
I think I would start to, it would be
like a little bit of foreplay. Oh I see.
You like to be like I can't wait to
yeah because the thing about anal sex,
it feels good cause it feels like you're
taking a really good shit. Ah, right,
right, right. I liked right.
I don't like diarrhea.
No one likes diarrhea but like right,
we all can get behind a really good shit.
Yeah I do. It's amazing. Like
a good shit feels so good.
And that's what anal sex feels
like. Like a good, like a really,
really satisfying one where it's like
you've had to go and then you're like,
your whole body is just like, ah, you
know those where you shiver and your,
your literal eyes cross like that's,
that's what it's like.
You make me want to take a shit. I
know, right? I never thought I'd say it,
but they know I have another
potential suitor for you
before you have sex.
If you want to be horny for two or three
hours like you never been in your life
and you have access to marijuana too good.
We'd listen to me. Okay. Okay.
I'm listening as her weight alone can
get you really hornier than normal,
but it's been under all take about 10
12 Bannon girl before you want to have
your sexual fun with your partner or
whatever you do or masturbate. All right.
Oh,
about an hour later when you fill it,
just kicking and smoke your weed done
and then go ahead and get horny and I
promise you it will be
millions of times more.
You'll be so blissfully horny
that you will not want to come.
Trust me.
It
sounds like maybe you could
pass it on to potential mates.
Can someone please try that and
see if it works? I think they have.
I mean my man right here.
It's the best idea.
I want someone listening to Nellie's
try that. No, no, don't advocate.
You don't find it.
Don't not do it.
Do not get anybody listening to this
show did not do what this man is doing.
What does that work? What if that's the
cocktail to be as Horny, happiness, joy?
Well, you know what? I never realized
Tommy is the timeline. He's like,
you have to take 10 to 12 Benadryl
at once. You wait an hour.
It's so many.
You have to wait a full hour hour to
fight off that Benadryl and your system.
Stay awake for an hour and then
smoke a ton of weed. Then get horny.
Then he goes.
Then it's not like he will get you.
You're going to get horny does then.
Then you got to get in whenever so
much my formula for when you're Horny,
it's so labor. All of this is so
much work. Too much work. God. Oh,
where was he and what
was he sucking on again?
All the makings of a perfect video.
Where was he?
How horrible is the lighting? What's
the ask? All these things vary.
Whether the angle on
the camera was so good.
Seeing the closet with the glow you
the garage for other potential suitors.
This is Matt. He harmed
me. Bdo never been on it.
Get harmed him for my app.
I swear I'm not wanting to go out,
run around with a quicker time.
I'm looking for a woman.
I'm not real picky or I know people say,
why are you when you get a lot better?
People do say that to him a lot.
Why are you settled down with his pig?
Super Haas.
Do you think his friends are like,
John,
you're really set in this bar
way low, bro. Yo, you're good.
You got a lot of people. A
lot gone number. That kitchen
light, it's always on.
That's a closet light bay that's not
in the kitchen. He got a yellow closet.
You got an course Kerscher about us still.
That's still photo.
He didn't even run his hand
around his hair. Right.
He said he didn't even go like this
when I'm looking for how could you know
Ron hated woman round around glass,
the tier three inches.
Towel,
1520 pounds. You might
like to cook. Clean. Nice.
Dragged me to all my appointments.
What? Five, three arms.
The other it vibes are,
I am too tall, but one 15 but he's
not too picky. So maybe he's like,
are you a little tall?
But,
and his friends would go eight. You're,
you're with a really tall lady right now.
You shouldn't settle for
this. They usually would
say, what are you doing with,
why are you with fucking tall g
every animal valid driver's license.
Can you drive him to his appointment?
It's a preferred we sent,
might go the pain clinic, but
it keeps me from to go to let that go.
I ain't quick.
Blah.
Yeah, you don't have to go to the pain
clinic. What is the pain clinic? Uh,
you got a manager. He's got
a lot. Is the weed store,
isn't that medical
marijuana shot? God is, is.
Maybe it's not. Is he
on a lot of style? Feet.
Go and get the methadone. Yeah, Methadone.
I know that would a pain clinic. Yes,
because you're out there by the way.
Dating question.
Yeah.
It's funny that you bring that up
because there's another side effect to a
certain medicines.
Did it help
if you've had any kind of direct POW this
order problems? I'm here to tell you,
forget that bag or forget about salads.
Forget about Dick and
plants and all that stuff.
I don't know if you believe me or not
that he like to see me smokes meth with a
small limp. Dick. Get hard to hear the
way and why is he a harder and harder?
Norris smoke harder. My
big get this. Unbelievable.
You're gay. You won't believe how
good it is. Not your straight.
You won't believe how good it bills.
Your Dick had become so sensitive
that you don't need lube.
You don't need spirit. He just kept that
Dick head this up and down four times.
It's this hot bed and do it and you will
shoot an enormous amount of very good
do these Dick White Cup.
Well,
you know who didn't believe him
and I'd rather they didn't believe me,
but when he smoked with me,
he put his dick.
I can't believe how big his dick was.
He jacked off for Joe and shots and those
companies every time there's like 49
and he's fine. He has no neuropathy
problems at home. It gets even harder,
thicker and more come even believes me now
he believes in me now. I just
caught that. He believes me now.
I believe me now hanging out with his
brother Jack Jack in math and his brother
takes his dick out.
Yeah.
The way he said Lou was the most
disgusting word. Don't need.
Oh,
how does this person have the
faculties to like upload this video
and like, oh, those are the
things that perplex me. It's like,
how did this guy get all that
done before she drove? Well,
and he's took time out from his lunch
at Applebee's to go in the bathroom
because you can also hear the
wait staff in the background.
You can hear order up like all that
clinking and clanking led to the Nachos.
Yup.
Pretty Great.
You know what weekend this weekend he's
going to take another bus. Oh my God.
We'll
get hard. So do you want to see me go
from a limp dick too hard day. I got it.
Thanks. Do it this weekend. He's
going to do what? You do. Tape it.
It's a small deck. Very lamp. Okay.
Watch it get harder and harder.
That's a proven fact, right? Let me know.
That bothered me a bit. If you say yes,
I'll show it to you.
Uh, how hard it gets. Wait,
explain it again and see if I'm live and
I want you to see we get hard while she
smoked this meth with my brother,
his brother up to his brothers,
his brothers packing a better.
I know it.
He couldn't believe how big his
brother's definitely in the low note.
What's interesting in that no
one's brought this up. A button,
Nikki and all these people that have
observed these videos, she's right.
Like how do these maniacs,
these fucking derelicts,
this easy now I guess like how was he
figuring out? You're right, I can hear,
only figure out how to do it myself.
Know how to do it. I got it, I got it.
And I have my faculties, he's got
a producer to just, ah, okay. Yeah.
Like how has the try it out
guy uploading that video.
How is he airdropping to like, do
you what I mean like her so, right.
How does he even know how to do a phone?
Probably it's so true.
But what's it's probably happening,
which is so much more ridiculous cause
he's probably like I made this video,
I want to upload it and he has to like
show someone like post this like yeah.
And then someone's like, Oh what is
this? I'm just talking about something.
And then they,
they have to take him through the sub.
Do you have a youtube account and
here's how you express it. And then,
and then you want to throw a title on
it, year four strokes and then, okay,
what's your thumbnail?
What's Amil you get to pick on that video.
You like this a lot better now.
It's fine.
It just needs to get out there right away.
And what led to him being
like gotta shoot this. Yeah,
I'm just getting my was the conversation
right before. That's what I'm saying.
He was having lunch with this brand cause
you can actually, you know, rest right.
Restaurant my shelter. So yes, people
have said it's a halfway house.
It seems like that it's
probably what it is.
Somebody shooting dice right off camera.
You're right. That's interesting.
We haven't thought about the moment
before. All these videos. That's it.
You know what I've been talking about
this. That's it. Going to share it.
I keep sharing it with tables.
A dude's and no one believes me
putting this message out there.
He's like GM, I'm telling you, it
goes from a little limp Dick. Yeah,
to a hardware. It's prompted
by some guy who's being like,
you never things I stopped smoking crack
and I get hard. No. Yup. Something like,
you know what I mean? Like I've had
sex with six months and he's like,
you know what really works? And then
that guy was like, that does that.
That's not true. He's like, Oh yeah.
He got fired up as someone who didn't
believe his story. I gotta be honest,
like I were a guy's struggling with,
I would like maybe be like, oh, I'm
gonna have something to this mouth.
Like he kinda got through to me.
I just want to tell your listeners like,
you will not do math,
do math if you've never done math and
you think it's going to give you a hard
dick. Like don't let that be the
reason you get involved with,
well no neuropathy issues.
But doctor drew is our biggest,
Dick was Dr Dre was saying that you
shouldn't do math either to get a doctor
came on and he was like never like this
is not a very good formula for erectile
dysfunction.
It works for him.
That's the thing is like
bringing the family and, and,
and he also went from like,
my brother didn't believe me and then he
believes me now meaning like there was
a time where like he was telling his
brother, his brother, the pros like you,
you would just match and the stick thing,
you're always talking about it.
He's like, give me the fucking pipe. And
then went through with and then was like,
I'm gonna pull my dick out right now, and
he dragged off in front of his brother.
I mean
probably happened over a month.
You know how you like to be courted
for my would look like he did it to his
brother. [inaudible] story
of this video. I need to know
how much of a frenzy was he in before he
stop.
I hate that.
To leave and the spirit,
you can be it.
Your ticket become so sensitive
to keeper become so sensitive
for straight people and gay people.
That's the funny thing.
Humans can do it.
Very inclusive drug promoter.
He was like, what are you trans by?
You can do it and you can try it. Yeah.
There's so many other
like good reasons to do.
The math seems like fun for other reasons.
Like energy,
the pick me up,
you clean your house
collage is being made.
I just never heard the side effect
of it. It's pretty cool. Pretty cool.
You don't hear about the good sides
to Matt. This is what you're saying.
How positive the Dicks of math was.
Never a Siri. You know the faces of Meth,
we saw that a face deteriorates.
We didn't see those.
The Dick's through that chart, you're
sort of just gotten harder and harder.
Brilliant. Again, you with the
good point. So we've never,
you just created a new meme. The dicks
of met. We're going to get a few posts
as they come for like zombies.
I don't like how he says sensitive
either though. Santa Tf. Yeah,
he's got a bit of a lift.
It became,
it had become so sensitive,
thick, hot, whack. Me Ask you this, Nikki,
do you prefer thick, hot white?
Come to just watery come.
Do you know what I mean?
Like why is that a thing for him?
But it has to be thick and
it's not healthy
are my husband's got so many.
We have to play this game
called horrible are hilarious.
We show you a video like a fuck that's
fucked up or funny and we'll get you out
of here. I know you've got
to go. Is this funny to you?
Ah,
how much you liked it?
Okay,
here it is. Tell me what you
think. Okay. Okay, here it is.
It's all,
yeah.
Oh,
please do.
horrible. Horrible. Horrible.
Okay. Today. I hate it.
It bounced off the tray.
You know he's okay. He's fine. He's fine.
He's not watching. He landed
on a trashcan. I know,
but I do not like that at
the trashcan wasn't there.
We wouldn't even play
because he would not be fun.
Yeah.
Yeah. But you had to now, but you had to
assuage her fears that he wasn't dead.
So funny. Let's just play this out. Sure,
sure. You don't have to convince me.
Hold on a second. I already closed it.
God Damn it. Where to go was like a,
it sounds like a fire rocket going off.
And then just like even hear him.
Yeah.
Alright. Both of your associate pads. Now
I'm convinced she's associate bad deal.
Just that fun. It's so
funny. As long as he's,
I thought you were wanting from us.
Nikki. I, you are a woman of
sympathy. Oh, okay. He's okay.
He's okay. That's okay. The screams.
Oh No, no, no, no, no. He's not good.
Oh,
he's definitely not good.
That's a good screen screen.
It's funny. It's, yeah.
I mean,
I don't like watching it get hurt.
That's funny. This screams silly.
Okay.
A, yeah. Yeah, he's fine.
What's this one? This
is in here. What is this
they do in Japan? No, no, no.
What is that? What are they
doing? They do a prank show
where they set up cameras and
like if you're being pranked,
I get shot in the like,
it seems like someone broke in and
shot me shit out of this one guy.
He's scaring one person to think that like
people are being shot around him. Yes.
There's a mass shooting.
Like there's a fucking
like that's the prank there.
Tom's laughter and joy and I like
that at all. It's pretty bad.
I mean that guy is going to
have PTSD from that. Yeah.
There's certain breaks I don't like
to, yeah. When it's too mean spirited,
he's like, oh, don't fuck with him.
No. For the snap. I
already hate it. I hate it.
I know what's about to
happen yet and I ain't got
no date. Your finger, you
find your through your bank,
that accent plus an animal
in a video equals yeah.
The animals and I can never get time.
Oh whoa.
Oh Johnson
the alligator.
And now they're going to toss it in
the corner cause they're mad at it.
But you didn't know they just did it. It's
animal abuse. Oh, I hate it. I hate it.
May I interject a point here
about these crocodiles? Uh,
I don't know if you know this. It was a
cast member on road rules Australia, uh,
and run nine, late nineties. I forget
why. Anyways, we did a crocodile farm,
whatever mission I think. And he was so
cool. I got to hatch a baby crocodile.
Oh yes.
Now here's the thing.
Within seconds of that thing coming
out of its shell, it bit me what,
and those teeth are hard. They're
sharp as fuck. So that baby car,
that was a baby crocodile. Oh.
And that thing was like a team,
like a preteen one maybe. Oh my
God. And so when they're born,
they're extremely painful.
That was really cool. Yeah.
And then they wanted us to cut up a
pig and serve the pig parts to the
crocodiles. And I was like,
I think I'm a vegetarian.
Like they handed us machetes and they're
like, cut up the pig. And I'm like,
I can't. I'm sorry. I can't. And I
became a vegetarian for like a week. Wow.
That's all week. I last until we went to
Mcdonald's and I had to eat. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. One more. They call it in Australia.
Oh, I don't like this one. Oh,
I hate balloons.
Better do something.
What? Oh no, it's a pair
of the light is fine. Yeah.
Hang on. Hang on her. Oh God. Ah.
See how she's laughing? Tom, do
you see the joy in making space?
So it seemed like it was an
even split with Nikki though.
Thud into that dumpster. I hated that
video at first, but then the side,
just when I close my eyes,
the sound, the sound is good.
The sound is funny on the skier.
He, yeah, that was funny. Yup.
But I don't want to hear, oh,
someone breaking their leg.
Sure. That's awful, right?
That that's a normal reaction I'd say
to, all right. Everyone's learning,
everyone's learning.
I have a bunch of girls here.
If you've seen my regular sites,
you'll see there's suddenly all kinds
of pictures of me at other girls and
videos is going to be
showing up very shortly.
We'll have a big party here this weekend
that was all swollen.
So yes, I thought it, you know, being
healthy. I mean whole bunch of vegetables.
Oh No. Yeah. Oh No. I'm not sure
that was the best idea. No. Okay.
Well that was an in futility.
Oh,
why would she, do you have any
idea how long ago was holding that?
Was that a rooster? Yeah, I
switched to be proud of her.
I'm proud of her too. I love that. I've
felt like anxiety from you. You're like,
what's that?
She was going to break something now,
don't you feel as a lady,
I don't know if you feel the same way.
Tell me if you do that.
These fart videos are just,
you're just leaving money on the table
if you're not doing them as a woman.
I mean, I was just the way I do about
being like, eh, that's, that's fine.
Easy money. What'd you do it if
you're like, I'm having that. Never,
never ever, ever, ever but not,
okay. Here's the thing though,
we're putting your brain $50 our
reality right now into that scenario.
What if you're like, fuck,
I need like this would be,
I can make 500 bucks in an hour this
afternoon that would pay my rent or
whatever. You don't want
to be someone some day that
like people like, no, I just,
I would rather starve.
What if you wore a wig and you call it
called on that dog mask right there and
you're like woo name's Cara and
then you know you just have a home.
A run for our money. Yeah, I mean
see what I'm saying? I am a Vegan.
She said she would kick people in
the balls. How are you having anal,
you're a Vegan and my shit all
day. And you go, I do. It's great.
Really hot in here too.
Cause it's like the 90 outside
this woman. So I'm in a room.
It's a hero. I kinda liked her.
I liked her too. I respect
this a lot. It's really high.
That one's all right.
Listen,
why not profit?
I would do it in an assault.
Guys, fucking lameness.
There are so many freaks out there.
They'll love this stuff.
That's what I'm saying. It's easy
money. Oh, she's out of breath.
Had knocked the wind out of her.
She's out. She read. She said,
oh no.
Like,
oh my God. So this woman does
these videos for people a lot.
Now I would chosen dried apricots.
That makes up the front girls weekend too.
So she's just like, girls, I gotta
gotta do some content. They're like,
what's your channel?
Do you do like arts and crafts?
You know what I'm telling
you about it later
and she can you imagine
them just like putting,
they're putting a cup up to the
door to hear what she's doing.
What is she doing in there? What
is her, is she into Asm Mar?
That would be kind of a weird,
right, because she's doing
an Asr Marvin. No. Yeah.
I love this, this new design,
this new level of like, what's the
conversation before somebody who stops
what they're doing and makes these videos.
You're right. It's just like,
what was she doing before this?
In between going to the beach with
the girls and like dinner, you know,
you have the downtime where everyone
kind of like goes off into their own
getting dressed, just like Kinda,
some girls are napping and she's just,
you know, making some fart
content. Some money. Yes. Money.
She is awesome. Yeah. Um, look, Nikki,
it's always fun to have you here.
I wish we got signed to be, you know, we
gotta get you Outta here for something.
So where can people see you or what's
coming up? Anything on the road.
I'm going to, I'm going to be
in Cleveland, uh, next weekend,
the 20th and 21st at the
polarities. The best. So fun.
I haven't been there in so long.
I'm so excited.
You have to eat at the restaurant
across the way there. Oh my God.
The greenhouse tavern. Yeah, that sounds
good. God. Okay. Okay, sounds good.
I'll definitely go there then.
And then, um, and then, uh,
Sacramento at the punchline and then
Providence, Rhode Island for, um,
New Year's, the comedy connection. Yay.
A ton of dates coming up every week.
And I'm on the road cause I'm doing a
Netflix special and the spring leading up
to that. And so you know on
the road every weekend. Yeah.
laser.com tornadoes and
I have a radio show.
If you have Sirius XM radio or
you're driving a rental car,
I'm tuning into my show. It's every
morning, two hours every morning,
10 to 12 eastern on channel 95
comedy central radio called you up.
And then we also have a podcast with the
bus stuff that's free that you can and
you sometimes have the puddle boy on
with you. Oh, Andrew Collin. Yeah.
Andrew Collin. What you went
to high school with that
right high school with him.
He is one, he's like my best friend
and he's on the show all the time.
He travels with me on the road.
He is a, yeah. Follow Andrew.
Andrew Collins. So funny. And
He loves you guys and uh, yeah,
he's uh, he's going to be big.
He's going to be something. Yeah.
If I have anything to say about it. Good.
Andrew Collin, he's the future of comedy.
There you go. Yeah, I'm really, I really
love her. She's so funny. Yeah, he is.
He's hilarious. Um, all right. Uh,
that's it, Nikki. Thanks again.
And we'll leave you guys on the phone.
It was, uh, made by DJ Crown Molding.
It's my dad's nuts featuring Andrew
Santina. I love, fuck. I'm an ass.
I'm a big ass liquor.
I see are nuts are nuts. I see are
not so common that I see are not nuts.
Nuts. Yeah. I see are nuts.
I see are not like Helena tie or not
as I see are not psychologists or not,
not as nuts.
Nothing wrong.
Yeah.
Big Ass liquor.
Sure.
And he showed me his,
oh no. Like my dad's nuts.
My Bide, my dad's nuts.
My Dad's nuts. Bide my, my
dad's nuts. No, my dad's nuts.
My mind, my dad's nuts. My Dad's might by
my dad's nuts. No, like Kurt
on. They're just my nuts son.
Blake.
No,
like
big ass.